Thank you for listening to the rest is history for weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much loved chat community. Go to the rest is history.com and join the club that is the rest is history.com Listeners to the rest is history will know that we do love a good sequel on the show. So 100 Years War, sequel. French Revolution, sequel. Captain Cook and Nelson haven't had the sequel yet, but I promise they're on their way. And I'll tell you what else is on its way. Our second Sunday Times bestselling book, The Restless History Returns, is out in paperback in May. And in in its pages what we do is to take you, the beloved reader, through an alphabetical miscellany of history's best and most bizarre moments from Cortez
感谢收听《其余皆是历史》（The Rest is History），如需收听每周独家节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 theresahistory.com 并加入俱乐部，即 theresahistory.com。《其余皆是历史》的听众都知道，我们在节目中非常喜欢看精彩的续集。所以，百年战争，续集。法国大革命，续集。库克船长和纳尔逊还没有续集，但我保证它们正在筹备中。我还要告诉你另一部即将推出的作品：我们第二本《星期日泰晤士报》畅销书《历史的余音再次响起》（The Rest is History Returns）将于五月推出平装版。在这本书中，我们带你——亲爱的读者——穿越历史最好也是最离奇的时刻的字母顺序杂集，从科尔特斯
to Chaucer, from fashion to Freemasons, from Mitford's to monkeys. And on top of that, there's a pub quiz and there's a whole host of puzzles to test your historical metal. So if you enjoy a sequel as much as we do, why not send your future self a little treat and pre-order your paperback of The Rest is History Returns now. There's a big knock at the door, 8 o'clock. Everybody's just sort of gliding down slowly from the whole day, sort of freaking about. Everyone has managed to find their way back to the house. TV is on with the sand off and the record player is on.
到乔叟，从时尚到共济会，从米特福德家族到猴子。除此之外，还有一个酒吧问答和各种谜题来考验你的历史功底。因此，如果你和我们一样喜欢续集，为什么不给未来的自己送上一份小礼物，现在就预订平装版的《历史的余音再次响起》呢？外面有很大的敲门声，8点钟。每个人都从一整天的疲惫中慢慢缓过神来，有点大惊小怪。大家都设法回到了房子里。电视开着，声音是关着的，唱片机正在播放。
Strobe lights are flickering. Maryam Faithful has just decided that she wanted a bath and has wrapped herself up in a rug and is watching the box. Bang, bang, bang, this big knock at the door and I go to answer it. Oh, look, there's lots of little ladies and gentlemen outside. He says, read this. Unmistakable tones there of Keith Richards, of course, and he was being interviewed in Rolling Stone on the 19th August 1971 about one of the most notorious episodes, really from the 1960s, one of the kind of iconic moments.
频闪灯在闪烁。玛丽安·费思福刚刚决定洗个澡，于是裹着一条地毯正在看电视。砰、砰、砰，外面传来巨大的敲门声，我去开门。哦，看，外面有好多小小的绅士淑女。他说，读读这个。毫无疑问，那是基思·理查兹的语气，当然，他在1971年8月19日接受《滚石》杂志采访时，谈到了20世纪60年代最具争议的事件之一，可以说是最具标志性的时刻之一。
And it is the evening of the 12th of February 1967. The scene is Keith Richards' country house at Redlands in Sussex and the man at the door is Chief Inspector Gordon Dynley of the West Sussex Constabulary and Dominic, he's come basically to search the house and to arrest as many Rolling Stones as he possibly can, hasn't he? Make an example of them. Yes, so this is the cue for one of the most famous trials in post-war British history. It's a very funny story, sort of tragicomic, and it's a brilliant window. I think it's the cultural life of Britain in the late 1960s.
那是1967年2月12日的傍晚。场景是基思·理查兹位于萨塞克斯郡雷德兰兹的乡村住宅，门前的人是西萨塞克斯郡警察局的总督察戈尔和·丁利，多米尼克，他来这里基本上是为了搜查这所房子，并尽可能多地逮捕滚石乐队的成员，对吧？杀鸡儆猴。是的，这就是战后英国历史中最著名的审判之一的导火索。这是一个非常有趣的故事，有点悲喜剧色彩，也是一个极好的窗口。我认为它是20世纪60年代末英国文化生活的一个缩影。
So last time we looked at the rise of the Rolling Stones and the way that they became folk devils in early 60s Britain. And today we're going to focus on the Rolling Stones in the last three years of the 60s. So we have the Redlands drugs case, a huge story at the time in Britain, front page news day after day. We have the tragic fate of Brian Jones, who is set up as this sort of doomed protagonist last time.
所以上次我们探讨了滚石乐队的崛起，以及他们在60年代初的英国如何成为“民间恶魔”。今天我们将把重点放在60年代最后三年里的滚石乐队。因此，我们有雷德兰兹毒品案，这在当时的英国是一个轰动一时的大新闻，连续几天登上头版头条。我们还有布莱恩·琼斯的悲惨命运，他上次被塑造成一个注定悲剧的主角。
And we have the probably the two most celebrated concerts the Rolling Stones ever gave, two of the most celebrated rock concerts of all time, their appearance at Hyde Park and their appearance at the Altamont Raceway in 1969. There will be a lot of drugs. And perhaps surprisingly, given that this is an apparently trivial story about a rock band who are still in their mid-20s, there'll be an awful lot of death. So we're in February 1967, 1967, the summer of love of psychedelia. So not natural territory for the stones, certainly as they promote themselves, one might argue. And this will be
我们还有滚石乐队举办过的可能最著名的两场演唱会，也是有史以来最著名的两场摇滚音乐会，即他们在1969年海德公园和阿尔塔蒙特赛车场的演出。这里会有很多毒品。也许令人惊讶的是，考虑到这是一个关于几个二十多岁的摇滚乐队成员的看似微不足道的故事，其中会包含大量的死亡。所以我们回到了1967年2月，1967年，迷幻摇滚的爱之夏天。因此，这绝对不是滚石乐队的自然领地，至少在他们宣传自己的时候，有人可能会这么认为。这将是
a bit of the context for the story you're about to tell, isn't it? So what's the broader political context? So the mood has changed since the early 60s. When we set up the stones last time, we talked about the affluent society, a lot of money sloshing around in 1963-64, it's the end of the 13 years of Toryism. Harold Wilson's Labour government are now in office, but they have kind of got into trouble. They've been in for three years or so, they're in a bit of a mess economically. There's a growing sense of anxiety about the state of the nation and about social and cultural change, I think. So the mood of the 60s, it's never one thing, it's kind of shifted. For The Stones, life seems to be superficially, it seems to be good.
你即将讲述的故事的部分背景，对吧？那么，更广泛的政治背景是什么？因此，自60年代初以来，人们的心境已经发生了变化。当我们上次介绍滚石乐队时，我们谈到了富裕社会，1963至1964年间有大量资金在流动，这是托利党执政13年的结束。哈罗德·威尔逊的工党政府现在掌权了，但他们陷入了一些麻烦。他们已经执政了大约三年，经济上陷入了一些混乱。我认为，人们对国家现状以及社会和文化变化的焦虑感日益增强。所以60年代的心境从来不是单一的，它发生了一些转变。对于滚石乐队来说，生活表面上看起来似乎很不错。
They've had six British number ones, four American number ones, very famous songs, Satisfaction, Get Off My Cloud, Paint It Black and Ruby Tuesday. They've been to the United States three times, Triumphant Tours, they've been twice to Australia and New Zealand, they've been often to Europe. There is a slight sense I think by 1967, I think you're dead right that they are out of time, that their music has, you know, the sort of the blues edged music with which they came to prominence in 1964 is no longer what people want in 1967. Yeah, what the kids are grieving are sitars. They want sitars. They want people laughing uncontrollably for no reason at the end of a track.
他们有过六首英国冠军单曲，四首美国冠军单曲，非常著名的歌曲有《Satisfaction》、《Get Off My Cloud》、《Paint It Black》和《Ruby Tuesday》。他们去过美国三次，进行了凯旋般的巡演，去过澳大利亚和新西兰两次，也经常去欧洲。我认为到1967年，有一种轻微的感觉，我认为你说得完全对，那就是他们已经与时代脱节了，他们的音乐已经——你知道的，他们在1964年崭露头角时那种带点蓝调边缘的音乐，在1967年已经不再是人们想要的了。是的，孩子们渴望的是西塔琴。他们想要西塔琴。他们想要人们在一首曲子的结尾莫名其妙地无法控制地大笑。
They want bits played backwards. Exactly. So there's a slight sense that the Stones are beginning to copy the... I mean, they've always been in the shadow of the Beatles, as we established last time, that they are becoming a little bit slavish to the Beatles. Their most recent album was Between the Buttons, which was released in January 1967. It's a little bit more sort of folky and a bit more psychedelic than their previous records. They are Tom, like so many blues musicians before them,
他们想要倒放的片段。没错。因此，有一种轻微的感觉，那就是滚石乐队开始模仿……我的意思是，正如我们上次确定的那样，他们一直生活在披头士乐队的阴影下，他们变得有点盲目模仿披头士乐队。他们最近的一张专辑是1967年1月发行的《Between the Buttons》。它比他们以前的唱片更具民谣风格和迷幻色彩。汤姆，就像他们之前的许多蓝调音乐家一样，
they are at a crossroads. Now, they're also, of course, by this point, national celebrities and international celebrities. So in the last episode, we heard how they turned into kind of folk devils. Well, there's, I mean, literally a Faustian pact in that sense, isn't it? Yeah.
他们正处于一个十字路口。当然，到这个时候，他们也成为了全国名人乃至国际名人。所以在上一集里，我们听到了他们是如何变成某种“民间恶魔”的。嗯，从某种意义上说，这字面上就是一个浮士德式的契约，不是吗？是的。
That they have cast themselves as devils when in fact, in all kinds of ways, they're not really, you know, they like collecting cricket memorabilia. Yes. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. They're like war films. They're like 1950s war films and things like that. So particularly Mick Jagger, Keith Richards and Brian Jones have become names. They've made that sort of transition to becoming names that people who are not really interested in their music will automatically recognise. They'll be in the gossip columns. They will be mentioned as sort of shorthand for youth.
他们把自己塑造成了恶魔，而实际上，在各种意义上，他们真的不是，你知道的，他们喜欢收集板球纪念品。是的。是的，没错。没错。他们喜欢战争电影。他们喜欢20世纪50年代的战争电影之类的内容。因此，尤其是米克·杰格、基思·理查兹和布莱恩·琼斯，已经成为了家喻户晓的名字。他们完成了这种转变，成为了那些对他们的音乐并不真正感兴趣的人也会自动认出名字的人。他们会出现在八卦专栏里。他们会被提及，作为青春的某种代名词。
And in a way that perhaps is no longer the case, would you say? Yeah, because there is a genuinely homogenous culture, national culture, and to some extent, I suppose, a Western international culture has emerged really, I mean, I guess it existed in the form of Hollywood, but, you know, they could walk down the street in Chicago and they would be immediately recognized in a way that would not have been possible for a music hall singer in the 1890s or something. So they're always being mentioned, those three in particular, and at Media Accounts of Swinging London 1965-1966, they loved nothing better than hanging around with old Atonian art dealers and aristocrats and things. And their success, now you mentioned the house, Redlands. I think that's actually really important. Their success is symbolized above all
以一种或许不再适用的方式，你会这么说吗？是的，因为确实出现了一种同质化的文化，国家文化，并在某种程度上，我想，西方国际文化真正浮现了，我的意思是，我想它曾以好莱坞的形式存在过，但是，你知道的，他们可以在芝加哥的街头漫步，并且会被立刻认出来，这在1890年代的音乐厅歌手身上是不可能发生的。所以他们总是被提及，尤其是那三个，而在1965-1966年“摇摆伦敦”的媒体报道中，他们最喜欢的就是和老伊顿公学的艺术商以及贵族之流厮混。他们的成功，现在你提到了那所房子，雷德兰兹。我认为这其实真的很重要。他们的成功首先象征着
by their houses. The British are famously obsessed with property. All of them by this point in the late 60s have bought country houses. So Mick Jagger has a place, a Victorian house called Stargroves in Hampshire. Charlie Watts has a 16th century house called Peckham's with staff near Lewis. Brian Jones, a house that we'll be returning to. Cotsford Farm Sussex, again 16th century, most famous owner was A.A. Milne. And has a swimming pool, of course. Bill Wyman has a tremendous house. He bought Geding Hall in Suffolk, which had been built in 1480.
他们的房产。英国人出了名地痴迷于房产。到了60年代末，他们所有人都在乡村买下了房子。所以米克·杰格在汉普郡有一处名为Stargroves的维多利亚式宅邸。查理·沃茨在刘易斯附近拥有一处名为Peckham's的16世纪住宅，配有仆人。布莱恩·琼斯则拥有一座我们将再次提及的房子，萨塞克斯郡的科茨福德农场，同样是16世纪的建筑，最著名的主人是A·A·米尔恩。当然，里面还有一个游泳池。比尔·怀曼拥有一座极好的房子。他在萨福克郡买下了吉丁庄园（Geding Hall），该建筑建于1480年。
And that came with the title Lord of the Manor of Geding and Thornwood. I mean the thing about this is it's interesting. They are kind of classier houses than the houses, say, the Beatles buy apart from Paul who lives in central London. Yes. They're more the kind of houses that working class people who've suddenly come into money would buy because they're not familiar with the world of what you would buy that people who hang out with old Etonians would have. Yeah, I get that's true. I mean, they've bought the houses that Victorian industrialists buy.
它还带有吉丁和索恩伍德庄园领主的头衔。我的意思是，关于这一点很有趣。与披头士乐队买的房子相比——除了住在伦敦市中心的保罗之外——它们算得上是更有品位的房子。是的。它们更像是那些突然暴富的工人阶级会买的房子，因为他们不熟悉那些与老伊顿公学毕业生交往的人会买的世界。是的，我想这是真的。我的意思是，他们买下了维多利亚时代的实业家会买的房子。
I mean, this is the house that you buy, I would say, when you've made an awful lot of money from ball bearings in 1840 and you want a country house and you want to ride to Hounds and you send your son to a public school and all of those things. The Stones are very, very keen to certainly Mick Jagger is extremely keen to embrace this lifestyle. But they're alert to history and to the kind of the cache that a house would have because maybe someone who had formerly lived there in a way that buying houses in a state on a hill in Surrey, a gated community in Surrey, wouldn't have that kind of pattern.
我的意思是，这就是当你通过1840年的滚珠轴承赚了巨额财富，想要一栋乡村别墅，想要骑马打猎，并把儿子送到公学等等所有这些事情时，你会买的房子。滚石乐队非常非常热衷于——特别是米克·杰格极为热衷于拥抱这种生活方式。但他们对历史保持着警惕，也意识到房子所承载的那种声望，因为或许以前有人在那里住过，这与在萨里山上的庄园、萨里的封闭式社区买房子的那种格局是不同的。
These are not stock-focused houses. These are houses in which they can, if they want, entertain the daughter of a duke, as Mick Jagger very much loves to do. So Keith Richard House Redlands is part of this kind of Sussex, Lutyens-esque, Edwardian, Tudor beams kind of stuff. So it's actually 16th century, isn't it? But it's got that, you could imagine a murder mystery happening in the 1920s there. You could absolutely imagine that, or you can imagine Henry James living there at the turn of the century or something of that ilk, exactly. So the incongruity, I think, becomes an enormous part of this story.
这些不是那种批量建造的房屋。这些是他们可以随心所欲地招待公爵女儿的房子，正如米克·杰格非常乐意做的那样。所以基思·理查兹的房子雷德兰兹是萨塞克斯这种鲁琴斯风格（Lutyens-esque）、爱德华时代、都铎式横梁建筑的一部分。所以它实际上是16世纪的，对吧？但它具有那种特色，你可以想象20世纪20年代那里发生了一起谋杀悬疑案。你完全可以想象得到，或者你可以想象亨利·詹姆斯在世纪之交或其他类似时期住在那里，完全如此。所以，我认为这种不协调感成为了这个故事极其重要的组成部分。
So Redlands has been in Richard's possession for a couple of years. We'll talk a bit about the house later on. On the 11th of February, Saturday the 11th of February, the Stones had been working on their next album, The Disastrous, Their Satanic Majesties Request at the Olympic Sound Studios in London. And they finish up and they all go their separate ways and Jagger and Richards drive with a group of friends down into Sussex to Redlands. They're going to spend the weekend there and it's a very, very late 60s sort of coterie
因此，雷德兰兹在理查兹手中已经有几年了。我们稍后会聊聊这栋房子。2月11日，星期六，滚石乐队一直在伦敦的奥林匹克之声录音室创作他们的下一张专辑——灾难性的《撒旦陛下请求》（Their Satanic Majesties Request）。他们完成了工作，各自各奔东西，杰格和理查兹与一群朋友驱车前往萨塞克斯的雷德兰兹。他们打算在那里度过周末，这是一个非常非常具有60年代末色彩的小集团
that they have. So one woman who's Marianne Faithfull, who's 20 years old, who had been well known now for three years. She's Mick Jagger's girlfriend. She'd made her kind of explosion onto the scene with the song as tears Tears Go By. Lovely song written by Jagger and Richards. Kind of sexy posh. Sexy posh, exactly. Yes. And they've got a couple of old Etonian sort of art dealers with them, Robert Fraser and Christopher Gibbs. So Robert Fraser is called Groovy Bob, isn't he? Groovy Bob. And they have sort of various other hippies and kind of hangers on who are called things like Acid King David and stuff like this. Camberwell Carrots all around.
他们拥有这样的伙伴。其中一位女性是玛丽安·费思福，她今年20岁，已经成名三年了。她是米克·杰格的女友。她凭借歌曲《As Tears Go By》在乐坛爆发。这是一首由杰格和理查兹创作的可爱歌曲。带点性感的高贵。性感的高贵，没错。是的。他们带了几个老伊顿公学的艺术商朋友，罗伯特·弗雷泽和克里斯托弗·吉布斯。所以罗伯特·弗雷泽被称为“时髦鲍勃”（Groovy Bob），对吧？时髦鲍勃。他们还有各种各样的嬉皮士和跟班，名字叫“酸王大卫”之类的人。到处都是坎伯韦尔胡萝卜烟卷。
Exactly. So they go down there Saturday night, Sunday, as you described in your lovely reading, they have been out kind of freaking about as Keith Corsa, but actually they behave as people do behave on kind of weekends in the country, they'd be gone for some nice walks, they've taken photos of each other, they've gone on the beach. So it's not a bacchanal. That's the key thing.
没错。所以他们在周六晚上去了那里，周日，正如你在你那优美的朗读中所描述的那样，正如基思所说，他们出去到处鬼混，但实际上他们的行为就像人们在乡下度周末时的行为一样，他们去散了些步，互相拍了照，去了海滩。所以这不是一场狂欢。这才是关键所在。
They have been smoking dope, but it's not absolutely not a bacchanal. It's actually just strolling around chatting aimlessly. And then the police turn up at about 7.30, they've got the telly on, they're listening to records, Marianne Faith was having a bath. And the reason the police turn up is they have had a tip off from the News of the World newspaper, now defunct, but then a colossal multi-million copy selling newspaper that specialized in stories about vickers being caught in sex scandals. The News of the World had been tipped off almost certainly from one of the hangers on
他们一直在吸大麻，但绝对、绝对不是一场狂欢。实际上只是到处漫步，漫无目的地闲聊。然后警察在7点半左右出现了，他们开着电视，听着唱片，玛丽安·费思福正在洗澡。警察出现的原因是他们得到了《世界新闻报》的匿名举报——这份报纸现已停刊，但在当时是一份拥有数百万发行量的庞大报纸，专门报道牧师卷入丑闻的故事。《世界新闻报》几乎可以肯定是得到了屋内某个跟班的通风报信，
inside the house that the stones were there and there were a lot of drugs. The news of the world were very keen on this story because in a sort of complicated irony, they were already in conflict with Mick Jagger because they had falsely accused him of taking drugs openly in a London club earlier that year. What had actually happened is they'd got him mixed up with Brian Jones. Mick Jagger was outraged and was suing them for libel. And so the news of the world were desperate to get dirt on Mick Jagger. It is the kind of newspaper that bears a grudge.
得知滚石乐队在那里，并且有很多毒品。世界新闻报对这个故事非常热衷，因为在一个复杂的讽刺中，他们已经与米克·杰格产生了冲突，因为他们早些时候曾在伦敦的一家俱乐部里公开虚假指控米克·杰格吸毒。实际发生的事情是，他们把他和布莱恩·琼斯搞混了。米克·杰格大为愤怒，并因诽谤起诉了他们。因此，《世界新闻报》急于搜集米克·杰格的黑历史。这正是一家记仇的报社。
It does bear a grudge, exactly. So they tipped off the police. The police had got a search warrant from a special sitting of magistrates in Chichester, and now they arrived 18 uniformed policemen, men and women. And actually, you know what? The raid reflects very well on Britain, I think. Everybody is extremely polite. So Keith Richards, he opens the door to Chief Inspector Diley and his officers and he says,
它的确记仇，没错。所以他们向警方通风报信。警察从奇切斯特的一个特别治安法官会议上获得了一份搜查令，现在他们抵达了，18名身穿制服的警察，男女都有。事实上，你知道吗？我认为这次搜查很好地反映了英国的风貌。每个人都极其礼貌。因此，基思·理查兹打开门迎面见到总督察迪利和他的警官们，他说，
you know, I've only got one request. I brought these cushions from Morocco. They're very expensive. Can you please make sure you don't tread on them? And do they avoid treading on them? They do avoid treading on them. With their massive policeman's feet. And actually this is not surprising because Keith Richards was very
你知道的，我只有一个要求。我从摩洛哥带了这些坐垫。它们非常昂贵。你们能确保不要踩到它们吗？他们避开踩到它们了吗？他们确实避开了。用他们那巨大的警察靴子。事实上，这并不令人意外，因为基思·理查兹非常
well regarded generally by his neighbours. They regarded him as a polite young man. Which he was. Yes, which he was. So the police arrived and some of them had been, you know, golly, this is going to be an eye opener. And actually they're slightly taken aback because actually all the guests are doing and listening to Bob Dylan records while getting ready to watch an old 1950s
受邻居们的尊崇。他们认为他是一个有礼貌的年轻男子。他的确是。是的，他确实是。所以警察到达了，其中一些人曾想，天哪，这可真是让人大开眼界。事实上，他们有点吃惊，因为实际上所有的客人在准备观看电视上一部1950年代的
gangster film on TV. And the only woman there is Marion Faithful. She has been having this bath. So when they come in, she grabs this gigantic fur rug and wraps herself in it. Which is unfortunate for her, isn't it? Because it enables an element of prurience to creep into the subsequent reporting. Salacious stories which are completely untrue, exactly. And actually, the policemen are not shocked particularly shocked by this. PC Don Rambridge, who was later interviewed about
老黑帮电影时，都在做的事情是听着鲍勃·迪伦的唱片。里面唯一的女性是玛丽安·费思福。她一直在洗澡。所以当他们进来时，她抓起一张巨大的毛皮地毯，把它裹在自己身上。这倒霉透了，对吧？因为这让随后的报道中渗入了一种窥阴癖的成分。充满恶意的故事，完全是子虚乌有，没错。实际上，警察对此并没有感到特别震惊。唐·兰布里奇警员（PC Don Rambridge）后来接受了关于
this, gave what I think was a slightly ungallant interview. And I think untrue. He said, she wasn't anything to look at anyway. She was obviously a dropoutant interview and I think untrue. He said she wasn't anything to look at anyway. She was obviously a dropout type, but I don't think, I mean she clearly was very pretty. So this was very harsh of P.C. Rambridge. The thing that really shocked them actually was the incongruity of the stones in this house. P.C. Rambridge, it gave us a bit of a shock. From the outside it's a beautiful house, oldie worldie, half beamed. Then you go inside, it's decorated in mauves and blacks, all the beams painted like that. It turned out to be a real ravers place.
这件事的采访，发表了一篇我认为略显不够绅士的采访。而且我认为是不真实的。他说，反正她也没什么好看的。她显然是个堕落分子。但他却说她没什么好看的。她显然是个堕落分子，但我认为——我的意思是她明显长得很漂亮。所以兰布里奇警员这番话未免太苛刻了。真正让他们感到震惊的其实是滚石乐队在这座房子里的不协调感。兰布里奇警员说，这给了我们一些震撼。从外面看，这是一座美丽的房子，古色古香，半露木梁。然后你走进去，里面装饰着紫色和黑色，所有的横梁都涂成那样。结果这里真是一个狂欢者的窝点。
It really hurt looking at the inside. I mean, that is 1967 summed up, isn't it? It's Sergeant Pepper. It's Edwardian, what is it? Lord Kitchener's Valet. Yeah, Lord Kitchener's Valet, exactly. But psychedelic and groovy at the same time. Exactly.
看到里面真的让人心痛。我的意思是，这就是1967年的缩影，不是吗？那是《佩珀军士》。那是爱德华时代的，什么来着？厨房长官的随从（Lord Kitchener's Valet）。是的，厨房长官的随从，没错。但同时又兼具迷幻和时髦感。没错。
So I think Keith, I don't, Lord Kitchener's Valet. Exactly. But psychedelic and groovy at the same time. Exactly. So I think Keith, I don't, but he still owns the house. I don't believe it's still, I would be surprised if it's still painted Mauve inside. I think I imagine- Tastefully done now. Tastefully done now. I think there's, do you know what? It would amaze me if there aren't nautical prints.
所以我想基思，我不——厨房长官的随从。没错。但同时又兼具迷幻和时髦感。没错。所以我想基思，我不——但他仍然拥有这栋房子。我不认为现在仍然是——如果里面仍然漆成紫色，我会感到惊讶。我想象——现在品味很高了。现在品味很高了。我觉得，你知道吗？如果有航海版画，我一点也不会感到惊讶。
What kind of, even dare I say a battle map of Trafalgar or something like that. I think that would reflect very well on him. We know he loves all that stuff. So he's got a library. He's got a very well furnished library by all accounts. So the police, do they find the drugs they're looking for? The short answer is, is in many ways, no. They're hoping for vast quantities of LSD and all this kind of thing.
甚至，我敢说，还有特拉法加海战的作战地图之类的东西。我认为那将很好地反映他的品味。我们知道他喜欢所有这些东西。所以他有一个图书馆。据各方说法，他有一个设施非常完善的图书馆。那么警察，他们找到了他们寻找的毒品吗？简短的回答是，在许多方面，并没有。他们希望找到大量的LSD以及诸如此类的东西。
And they don't find it. What they find are there are some amphetamines in Mick Jagger's green velvet jacket. These are actually Marianne Faithfull's. And there's quite a lot of stuff owned by Groovy Bob isn't there? Yes. So Mick says of these tablets, well these are actually mine, they were given to me by my doctor. But it's on Groovy Bob, Robert Fraser, the old Attonian art dealer that they find marijuana
但他们没有找到。他们发现的是，在米克·杰格的绿色天鹅绒夹克里有一些安非他命。这些其实是玛丽安·费思福的。而且“时髦鲍勃”名下有很多东西，不是吗？是的。所以米克谈到这些药丸时说，好吧，这些其实是我的，是我的医生给我的。但在“时髦鲍勃”——罗伯特·弗雷泽这位老伊顿公学艺术商身上，他们发现了大麻、
amphetamines and 24 white tablets, which he says, oh, don't worry about those. You know, they're just medicine or something. And actually they turn out to be heroin. And the police are sort of, he was the one man they said, oh, he was a very nice man, very well spoken, very polite. And he was as good as gold, they said of him. Do you know what?
安非他命和24片白色药片，他说，哦，别担心那些。你知道的，它们只是药或者别的什么。结果它们被证明是海洛因。警察有点——他是他们提到的唯一一个人，他们说，哦，他是个非常好的人，谈吐文雅，非常有礼貌。他们说他简直像金子一样好。你知道吗？
He wasn't just a Groovy Bob. He'd been Idi Amin's commanding officer in the King's African rifles. I mean, that's so 60s. So the news of the world anyway, they had enough for their story. They had the amphetamines in Mick Jagger's jacket and they had Groovy Bob's stash. And so a week later, they run this banner headline. They don't name them. They just say several stars. And then in March, the news breaks that Jagger and Fraser are going to be charged
他不只是个时髦鲍勃。他曾是阿明在非洲国王来复枪队中的长官。我的意思是，这太60年代了。无论如何，《世界新闻报》掌握了足够他们写报道的材料。他们有米克·杰格夹克里的安非他命，也有“时髦鲍勃”的藏货。于是在一周后，他们登出了这个横幅大标题。他们没有点名。他们只是说“几位明星”。然后在3月份，爆出了杰格和弗雷泽将根据1965年《危险药物法》被指控
for possession of drugs under the dangerous drugs act 1965. And Keith Richards is going to be charged for allowing the smoking of cannabis on his property. Although no drugs have been found on his person. Yeah, exactly. There's no evidence that he has, you know, it's never, it's never alleged that he's, I mean, I would be surprised if he hadn't. I don't want to, I don't want to end up in a legal battle with Keith Richards. It's very unlikely.
持有毒品的罪名。而基思·理查兹将被指控允许在他的房产内吸食大麻。尽管在他的身上没有发现任何毒品。是的，没错。没有证据表明他曾——你知道的，从来没有、从来没有人指控他——我的意思是，如果他没有吸过，我才会感到惊讶。我可不想和基思·理查兹陷入一场法律纠纷。这非常不可能。
It has been known. He's no stranger to that world, shall we put it that way? So on the face of it, listeners may say, well, this is a very trivial story. But at the time it becomes absolutely enormous. And I think it becomes an enormous story because it's symbolic of deeper changes. So when the Rolling Stones were growing up in the 40s and early 50s, drugs just simply were never an issue in Britain. In 1961, a Home Office committee had been set up to look at drugs.
这是有过先例的。他对于那个世界并不陌生，我们不妨这么说吧？因此，表面上看，听众可能会说，这其实是一个微不足道的故事。但在当时，它变得绝对巨大。我认为它之所以变成一个巨大故事，是因为它象征着更深层次的变化。因此，当滚石乐队在40年代和50年代初长大成人时，毒品在英国根本从来都不是一个问题。1961年，内政部成立了一个委员会来调查毒品问题。
And they basically said there was no need for us to ever do anything about this. There's no need for legislation or anything like that, because there are no drugs, there really are no drugs in Britain. The only people who take drugs are people who at the very top of society, who spend their holidays in North Africa or something, opium addicts, but the 99% of the population have no connection with the world of drugs whatsoever. But that's not quite true, is it? Because amphetamines are prescribed quite regularly.
他们基本上表示，我们根本没有必要对此采取任何行动。不需要立法或类似的东西，因为英国没有毒品，这里真的没有毒品。唯一吸毒的人是社会最顶层的人，他们在北非等地度假，也就是瘾君子，但99%的人口与毒品世界没有任何联系。但事实并非完全如此，对吧？因为安非他命是经常被处方开具的。
So aren't they called the housewife's friend? As Theo says, mother's little helper, Rolling Stones. Yes. So the sense of what drugs actually are, I guess, is evolving as well. It is indeed. Drugs are forced into the headlines really as the sixties proceed. The cannabis conviction figures go up, reflecting a wider picture. Clearly what's happening is first of all, young people have a lot more money.
所以它们不被称为“家庭主妇的朋友”吗？正如西奥所说，“母亲的小助手”，滚石乐队。是的。所以，人们对毒品实际到底是什么的看法，我想也在不断演变。确实如此。随着60年代的推进，毒品确实被推到了头条新闻的风口浪尖。大麻定罪的数据不断上升，反映出了更广泛的画面。显然发生的情况是，首先，年轻人有了更多的钱。
They're going out more often. The market for stimulants is bigger than ever before. And there's a rising cultural cache because of the associations with music. But also the supply is greater than before. People are taking more flights. They're going on ferries. It's much easier to import cannabis and cocaine from abroad. So people particularly from Morocco or from Turkey.
他们更频繁地外出。兴奋剂的市场比以往任何时候都大。由于与音乐的联系，它的文化声望也在不断上升。但供应也比以往更充足了。人们乘坐更多的航班。他们搭乘渡轮。从国外进口大麻和可卡因要容易得多。因此，人们特别是来自摩洛哥或土耳其的人。
There's more demand for drugs and there are more of them. And people are beginning to notice by 1967. So in 1964 and 65, the number of teenagers registered with the home office as addicts had gone up threefold. This has been reported. And I think what happens is that drugs becomes a symbolic issue.
对毒品的需求更多了，而且毒品也更多了。到1967年，人们开始注意到了。所以在1964年和1965年，在内政部注册为瘾君子的青少年人数增加了两倍。这已经得到了报道。我认为发生的情况是，毒品变成了一个象征性的议题。
So it's an issue in and of itself, but it also stands for deeper anxieties about the family, the impact of affluence on established habits, on immigration, cultural change, all of these things. And the impact of fame as well, because isn't there by 1966, is it Donovan? There's a documentary on ITV and he's the first kind of big musician to talk about taking cannabis. Yeah.
所以这本身就是一个问题，但它也代表了对家庭更深层次的焦虑、富裕对既定习惯的影响、移民、文化变迁等等。还有名气的影响，因为到1966年的时候，不是吗，是多诺万（Donovan）吗？ITV上有一个纪录片，他是第一个谈论吸食大麻的大牌音乐人。是的。
Or the Beatles, of course. But the Beatles don't kind of officially admit to taking drugs until, I think it's Paul McCartney talking about LSD in 67. Yes, I think it is 67. So actually just before the Redlands trial, interestingly. Yeah. But there is a sense that if you want to be groovy with it and like your heroes, then you should be smoking pot.
或者披头士乐队，当然。但披头士乐队并没有——可以说是——官方承认吸毒，直到，我认为那是保罗·麦卡特尼在67年谈论LSD的时候。是的，我想确实是67年。所以实际上就在雷德兰兹审判之前，有趣的是。是的。但有一种感觉，如果你想跟上潮流并且像你的偶像一样，那么你应该抽大麻。
Exactly. And I think no one's talking about that in 1964, but by 1967, people are talking about it a lot. It's in the media a lot. And of course, they're reporting the scenes from the counterculture in San Francisco and so on. I mean, the first reports of that are appearing in the British press. So when you combine that issue, so drugs, which is already symbolic of deeper changes and the Rolling Stones, who we established last time are the supreme folk devils for kind of middle England and for the newspapers of middle England, you get really the perfect story. And it reminds me a little bit, obviously it's completely different, but it reminds
没错。我认为在1964年没人谈论这个，但到了1967年，人们谈论得很多了。它在媒体上频繁出现。当然，他们也在报道旧金山等地反文化运动的场景。我的意思是，有关那里的第一批报道正在英国媒体上出现。因此，当你把这个议题——毒品（它已经象征着更深层的变化）与滚石乐队（正如我们上次确定的那样，他们是中产英格兰以及中产英格兰报纸终极的“民间恶魔”）结合起来时，你就得到了一个完美的故事。这让我想起了一点，显然它是完全不同的，但这让我想起了一点普富莫丑闻（Profumo scandal），那是1963年伟大的间谍丑闻和性丑闻，因为这是一个非常非常诱人且不可抗拒的故事，它实际上关乎一个陷入剧烈文化变革阵痛的社会的更广泛感受。它关乎高雅与庸俗的交织，不是吗？是的，人们对此喜闻乐见。是的，没错。我认为是庸俗的高雅。如果有老伊顿公学毕业生和不良行为，人们就会喜闻乐见。绝对喜闻乐见。所以实际上有趣的是，滚石乐队有点儿受了冤屈，因为
me a little bit of the Profumo scandal, the great spy scandal and sex scandal of 1963, in that it's a very, very enticing and irresistible story that's actually about a wider sense of a society that's in the throes of rapid cultural change. And it's about the intersection of poshness and seaminess, isn't it? Yeah, which people love. Yeah, exactly. CD poshness, I think. If there's old Atonians and there's bad behaviour, people love it. Absolutely love it. So actually the funny thing is the Stones are slightly hard done by because
尽管后来他们与毒品紧密联系在一起，显然还有基思·理查兹，但在当时他们并不是特别热衷的毒品使用者。所以比尔·怀曼和查理·沃茨被称为摇滚乐中最根正苗红的节奏组。是的，他们回去闲逛喝着可可……是的，没错。没错。基思·理查兹当时还没有吸食海洛因，媒体本可以讲述关于滚石乐队的另一个故事。所以米克·杰格在这之后几个月——我个人最喜欢的关于米克·杰格的事实——是他加入了乡村绅士协会（Country Gentlemen's Association），这是一个成立于1893年的土地所有者社团。我的意思是，这就是他选择如何利用自己的名气的方式。你从中能得到什么好处？嗯，就像你一样，汤姆，我想他大概得到了一件特别的理发师夹克，那种你去苏格兰庄园时穿的衣服。是的，三文鱼垂钓。所以基思·理查兹，你可以讲述关于他的故事是，他是一个收集海战书籍并将时间花在观看老战争电影上的人。查理·沃茨，对妈妈和妻子的忠诚模范，
although later on they become very much associated with drugs, obviously Keith Richards, at this point they are not especially keen drug users. So Bill Wyman and Charlie Watts were nicknamed the straightest rhythm section in rock and roll. Yeah, they're going back to hang out and have their cocoa and... Yeah, right. Exactly. Keith Richards is not yet taking heroin and there is an alternative story that the press could have told about the Rolling Stones. So Mick Jagger, a few months after this, my favourite Mick Jagger fact of all time, is that he joined the Country Gentlemen's Association, a land owner society that had
每个星期五都会给妈妈寄她最喜欢的蛋糕。但当然，这些故事当时从未出现在报纸上，因为它们不符合要求。人们对滚石乐队的想象是，正如评论家伊恩·麦克唐纳（Ian McDonald）所说，“颓废享乐主义的废墟象征”。所以那是人们唯一想讲述的故事。我认为这就是房子切入的地方。理查兹用现金以17,750英镑从一位皇家海军准将手中买下了这栋房子，这栋房子每天都出现在报纸上。为什么呢？
been first founded in 1893. I mean, that's what he chooses to do with his fame. What are the benefits you get for that? Well, like you, Tom, I think he gets probably a special barber jacket of the kind that you wear when you go to your estate in Scotland. Yeah, salmon fishing. So Keith Richards, the story you could tell about him is he's somebody who collects books about sea battles and spends his time watching old war films. Charlie Watts, the model of loyalty
我想因为还是那句话，这栋房子对评论家来说象征着更深层的东西。滚石乐队不应该住这样一栋房子。这是一种冒犯。就像披头士乐队获得大英帝国勋章（MBE）一样。这是对他们信仰的一切的一种冒犯。审判法官也住在萨塞克斯郡一栋16世纪的农舍里，名叫莱斯利·布洛克（Leslie Block），他也是一位曾在二战中因勇敢而获得勋章的前海军指挥官。我想他把滚石乐队视为——我认为他正是那种毫无疑问将滚石乐队视作冒犯的人。他是那种会说“这不是我们为之战斗的东西”的人。但悲剧在于，也许他和基思·理查兹会非常谈得来，他们本可以讨论阿布基尔湾战役的战术。是的，坎珀当。他们会喜欢所有这些的。真是太遗憾了。我知道。
to his mum and to his wife, sends his mum her favourite cake every Friday. But of course, those stories never appear in the papers at the time because they don't fit. The image that people want of the Rolling Stones is, as the critic Ian McDonald puts it, wasted emblems of decadent hedonism. So that's the only story that people want to tell. And I think here's where the house fits in. Richards had bought the house in cash for £17,750 from a Royal Navy Commodore and the house appeared in the newspapers every day. And why?
因为他后来发表了一场演讲，莱斯利·布洛克在霍舍姆耕作与农业协会（Horsham Ploughing and Agricultural Society）上。荣誉终身主席，米克·杰格。他因为在审判中失言而惹上了大麻烦，他与法律当局发生了巨大的冲突，他说：“我和我的同僚治安法官们，我们尽了最大努力来杀一杀这些滚石乐队的威风。”我认为这说出了国内许多当时有这种感受的人的心声。这些留着长发的年轻人太自以为是了，我们需要杀一杀他们的威风。
I think because it's again, the house is symbolic of something deeper to the critics. The Rolling Stones shouldn't be at such a house. It's an affront. It's like the Beatles, MBE. It's an affront to everything they believe in. And the judge at the trial, he also lives in a 16th century Sussex farmhouse, Leslie Block, and he is also a former naval commander who was decorated for bravery in the second world war. And I think he saw the Rolling Stones, I think he's the
有趣的是，他们针对的是滚石乐队，而不是例如披头士乐队，因为我刚刚查了保罗·麦卡特尼接受ITN采访谈论吸食LSD的日期，那是6月19日。所以这几乎是在滚石乐队被送上法庭前的一周。是的。但披头士乐队，你看，正如我们上次谈到的那样，国家媒体已经裁定披头士乐队是爱国英雄，因为他们征服了美国。
kind of person undoubtedly who saw the Rolling Stones as an affront. It's the kind of person who would say this is not what we fought for. But the tragedy is that probably he'd have got on brilliantly with Keith Richards and they could have talked about tactics at the Battle of Abakir Bay. Yeah, camp her down. They would have loved all that. Such a shame. I know.
所以他们不会对付他们。但滚石乐队是敌人。他们是合法的打击目标。是的，他们是合法的打击目标。所以我认为在某种程度上。审判于6月27日开庭，这是一个毫无悬念的结果。罗伯特·弗雷泽立刻认罪了。米克·杰格说，你知道的，我的医生告诉我，如果我感到压力大，服用安非他命是
And he, cause he later gave a speech, Leslie Block, to the Horsham Ploughing and Agricultural Society. Honorary life president, M Jagger. And he got in massive trouble with the legal authorities because he spoke out of turn about the trial and he said, I and my fellow magistrates, we did our best to cut these stones down to size. And I think that speaks to a lot of people in the country who felt like that at the time. These young people with their long hair have got ahead of themselves and we need to cut
可以的。对吧？因为安非他命，你知道，我们刚才说过，一直在被处方开具。这还不够好。而那个治安法官，这家伙布洛克，指示陪审团裁定他有罪。弗雷泽和杰格随后在媒体的众目睽睽之下被戴上手铐，被推着塞进一辆面包车，送到刘易斯监狱过夜，随后法庭转而处理基思·理查兹的案件。现在，基思·理查兹的罪行极其轻微。他被指控允许自己的房子被用于吸食毒品。他没有贩毒。没有人争辩说他自己吸毒了，但他在法庭上的露面
them down to size. And it's interesting that they're going for the stones and not, for instance, for the Beatles, because I just checked the date when Paul McCartney gave that ITN interview talking about taking LSD and it's the 19th of June. So it's pretty much a week before the stones are brought to trial. Yeah. But the Beatles, you see, as we talked about last time, the national media had decided that the Beatles are patriotic heroes because they had conquered America.
可能是审判中最令人兴奋的部分。因为此时，警察走上证人席，讲述了他们看到玛丽安·费思福赤身裸体、仅裹一条地毯的场景。我的意思是，她刚从浴缸里跳出来这件事，他并没有真正提及。理查兹的大律师勃然大怒，他说这完全是无关紧要的，它给人们留下了这次聚会性质的错误印象。它给人的印象是一种完全毫无根据的荒淫无度。公诉人就此质问基思·理查兹，而他惊人地回答说：“我们不是老头子，我们不担心琐碎的道德。”而这句“我们不担心琐碎的道德”成为了第二天各大报纸竞相登出的头条。
So they won't go after them. But the Rolling Stones are the enemy. They're fair game. Yeah, they're fair game. So I think there's a degree to it. The trial, which opens on the 27th of June, is a foregone conclusion. Robert Fraser pleaded guilty straight away. Mick Jagger said, you know, my doctor had told me it was
而且判决简直荒唐透顶。杰格被判入狱三个月，罗伯特·弗雷泽被判六个月，基思·理查兹被判十二个月。是的，这太疯狂了，不是吗？这显得完全疯狂，他们都非常震惊。米克·杰格在法庭上崩溃大哭。是的，他们还很年轻。
all right to take amphetamines if I was stressed. That's right, isn't it? Because amphetamines, you know, we've talked, said are being prescribed all the time. That wasn't good enough. And the magistrate, this guy Block, directed the jury to find him guilty. Fraser and Jagger were then handcuffed in the view of the press, kind of pushed and put into a van and taken to Lewis prison for the night while the court then turned to deal with Keith Richards. Now, Keith Richards' offence is incredibly minor. He has the charges that he has allowed his house to be used for the taking of drugs. He hasn't dealt in drugs. There's no argument that he's taken them himself, but his appearance
他们多大？二十多岁？理查兹是因为他的“琐碎道德”评论而受到如此严厉的判决吗，你认为呢？还是说他被视为某种程度上这群人中最邪恶的一个，或者到底发生了什么？我认为邪恶的名声可能来得稍微晚了一点，但我认为他在被告席上表现得很倔强。而且，也许你关于房子的理论也是因为他的房子吗？你怎么敢用这么好的一栋英国房子来……
in court is probably the most exciting bit of the trial. Because at this point, the police go into the witness box and tell their story about seeing Mary Anne faithful naked, but for a rug. I mean, the fact that she's just jumped out of the bath, he hasn't really mentioned. Richard's barrister is furious and he says this is completely irrelevant and it gives a false impression of what this gathering was like. It gives an impression of debauchery that is completely unwarranted. And the prosecutor asked Keith Richards about it and he said, fantastically, we're not old men, we're not worried about petty morals. And this, we're not worried about petty morals was the line that was then kind
是的。是的。我认为这绝对是一个因素。所以理查兹和弗雷泽被带到了沃尔姆伍德斯克鲁布斯监狱（Wyrmwood Scrubs）。杰格，汤姆，被带到了你那一带的布里克斯顿。哦，是的。就在我坐的地方附近。是的。现在杰格和理查兹第二天就通过保释获释，等待上诉，但弗雷泽没有，因为他根本站不住脚。他身上携带有海洛因。现在，有趣的是，滚石乐队本身和他们的粉丝一直有这样一种——我认为是疯狂的——阴谋论，认为这一切都是由英国建制派、由政府策划的。借用玛丽安·费思福的话说：“到1967年初，女王陛下政府中身居高位的人实际上将我们视为国家敌人。”
of emblazoned across the newspapers the next day. And the sentences are bonkers. Jagger got three months in prison, Robert Fraser got six months and Keith Richards got 12 months. Yeah, that's mad, isn't it? Which seems completely mad and they were all very shocked. Mick Jagger collapsed in tears in the court. Yeah, they are quite young men.
基思·理查兹，这就是我们被捕的原因。他们认为我们是一种威胁。汤姆，这不会让你感到惊讶，我认为这纯粹是胡说八道。你知道，花了比健康的时间多得多的时间去阅读和撰写关于哈罗德·威尔逊政府的文章后。威尔逊政府中的任何人会对这产生任何兴趣的想法简直是痴人说梦。当然。但我的意思是，建制派不仅仅是政府，对吧？你可以说它是媒体、警察、太平绅士（JP）和法官的交织。而且这不会——我的意思是，你不会说他们都在某个地方开了会……
What are they? Mid-twenties? Does Richards get that severe a sentence because of his petty morals comment, do you think? Or is he seen as somehow the most satanic of the lot or what's happening there? I think the satanic reputation probably comes along a little bit later, but I think he's been truculent in the dock. And also your theory about the house, perhaps, is his house perhaps? How dare you use such a fine English house to be...
他们多大？二十岁出头？你认为理查兹（Richards）被判得这么重，是因为他关于低俗道德的言论吗？还是因为他被视为这群人中最恶魔的一个，或者到底是怎么回事？我认为“恶魔般”的名声可能来得要晚一些，但我认为他在法庭上表现得很顽固。还有你关于房子的理论，也许，那是他的房子吗？你怎么敢用这么好的英国房子来……
Yes. Yeah. I think there's a definite element to that. So Richard and Fraser were taken to Wyrmwood Scrubs. Jagger, Tom, was taken to your neck of the woods in Brixton. Oh yeah. Just from where I'm sitting. Yeah. Now Jagger and Richard's were out the next day on bail pending appeal, but Fraser not, because he hasn't really got a leg to stand on him. He has had the heroine on him. Now, interestingly, the Stones themselves and their sort of fans have always had this, what I consider a mad conspiracy theory that this was all plotted by the British establishment, by the government. To quote Marianne Faithfull, by the beginning of 1967, there were highly placed people in
是的。是的。我认为其中肯定有这方面的因素。所以理查兹和弗雷泽（Fraser）被带到了沃尔姆伍德斯克鲁布斯监狱。贾格尔（Jagger）、汤姆，被带到了你所在的Brixton。哦，是的。就在我坐的地方附近。是的。现在贾格尔和理查兹在第二天就通过保释出狱等待上诉了，但弗雷泽没有，因为他根本没有什么站得住脚的理由。他身上确实有海洛因。有趣的是，滚石乐队本身以及他们的粉丝一直有一种——我认为是疯狂的阴谋论——认为这一切都是英国建制派、政府策划的。借用玛丽安·菲斯福尔（Marianne Faithfull）的话，到1967年初，有高层人士在
Her Majesty's government who actually saw us as enemies of the state. Keith Richards, that's why we got busted. They saw us as a threat. And it won't surprise you to know Tom that I regard this as absolute balderdash. You know, having spent far too much time than is healthy reading and writing about the Harold Wilson government. The idea that anybody in the Wilson government would have any interest in this at all is demented. Sure. But I mean, the establishment isn't just the government, is it? And you could say that it's the intersection of the media, the police and JP's and judges. And it wouldn't be, I mean, you wouldn't say that they'd all met up in a
女王政府中，他们实际上把我们视为国家敌人。基思·理查兹（Keith Richards），这就是我们被捕的原因。他们把我们视为威胁。汤姆，你不会感到惊讶，我认为这纯粹是胡言乱语。你知道，我花在阅读和撰写关于哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）政府的健康时间远远不够。认为威尔逊政府中的任何人对此会有什么兴趣的想法简直是疯狂。当然。但我的意思是，建制派不仅仅是政府，对吧？你可以说它是媒体、警察、太平绅士和法官的交汇点。而且这并不意味着，你不会说他们都在一个地方碰过头
gentleman's club and drawn it up, but we've talked about how they, you know, people are ready to go after the stones in a way that they're not after the Beatles, for instance. So there is a sense that a sniff of an opportunity and various segments of the British establishment are going to go after them. I would say that's not an exaggeration. At that point, your establishment becomes very, very broad because you're including hard-bitten newspaper journalists, you know,
绅士俱乐部里草拟出来的，但我们一直在讨论人们如何准备对付滚石乐队，这种程度是他们对披头士乐队所没有的。因此有一种感觉，只要有一点机会的苗头，英国建制派的各个阶层就会对付他们。我认为这并不是夸张。在那一点上，你的建制派变得非常非常广泛，因为你包括了老练的报纸记者，你知道，
who themselves love a drink and, you know, are no strangers to debauchery. You have the provincial police and you have random magistrates in different parts of the country. I mean, yeah, but Dominic, they're all squares. Well, maybe they are. But here's the thing, the squareest people of all and the most establishment people of all are the people who most eagerly stick up for and defend the Rolling Stones. Jacob Rees-Mogg's dad. This is the great twist of the story that I think is often slightly elided or confusingly
他们自己也喜欢喝一杯，对放荡的生活并不陌生。你有地方警察，还有英国各地各种各样的地方法官。我的意思是，是的，但多米尼克，他们都是老古董。嗯，也许他们是。但事情是这样的，最老古董的人以及最建制派的人，其实是最急于支持和捍卫滚石乐队的人。雅各布·里斯-莫格的爸爸。这就是这个故事的伟大转折，我认为这个转折常常被稍微忽略或令人困惑地
told. The tabloids love the story. The tabloids were like, brilliant, this is the ultimate story. The broadsheet newspapers, the establishment papers, the Telegraph, the Times and so on, pretty unanimous in saying that the Rolling Stones had been very harshly treated. The judge and the police had no business bringing their lifestyle into it, you know, the rug and the music or whatever, and that it was a disgrace that they had been handcuffed on their way out of when they were clearly no threat to anyone and they weren't going to run away or anything like that.
讲述。小报喜欢这个故事。小报觉得太棒了，这是终极故事。大报，也就是建制派报纸《每日电讯报》、《泰晤士报》等等，几乎一致认为滚石乐队受到了非常严厉的对待。法官和警察根本无权把他们的生活方式扯进来，你知道的，那块地毯和音乐什么的，而且他们在离开时被戴上手铐简直是一种耻辱，因为他们对任何人明显不构成威胁，也没有打算逃跑之类的。
And the man who makes this case most powerfully is, as I said, the father of Jacob Rees-Mogg, the ex-Tour EMP now, William Rees-Mogg, who's editor of the Times. And he picks out this perfect quotation from Alexander Pope, who breaks a butterfly on a wheel. Yeah, exactly. And it's one of the most famous editorials The Times has ever run, by the way. He says, it's outrageous to punish Mick Jagger because of, and I quote, the primitive prejudices of people who resent the anarchic quality of the Rolling Stones performances, dislike
而最有力的阐述这一点的人，正如我所说，就是雅各布·里斯-莫格的父亲，前托利党议员，现在《泰晤士报》主编威廉·里斯-莫格。他从亚历山大·蒲柏那里挑了一句完美的引言，大炮轰蚊子。对，没错。顺便说一句，这是《泰晤士报》发表过的最著名的社论之一。他说，惩罚米克·贾格尔是极其无理的，因为——我引用——“那些反感滚石乐队表演的无政府主义品质、不喜欢
their songs, dislike their influence on teenagers and broadly suspect them of decadence. And William Rees-Morog said, it's an unsigned leader. And so it's from the Times. And it said, British justice demands that Mr. Jagger, they used him as sort of shorthand for the defendants generally, is treated exactly the same as anyone else, no better and no worse. And the further twist about this story is you may say well thank goodness times on this is speaking for britain.
他们的歌曲、不喜欢他们对青少年的影响、并且大体上怀疑他们堕落的人们的原始偏见。”威廉·里斯-莫格说，这是一篇未署名的社论。所以它来自《泰晤士报》。上面说，英国司法要求贾格尔先生——他们用他来作为被告们的代名词——受到和其他任何人完全一样的对待，不多也不少。关于这个故事的另一个转折是，你可能会说，谢天谢地，《泰晤士报》在此时此刻代表了英国发声。
What it wasn't because when you look at surveys and polls from the time. Survey a couple of months later found that most young people thought that mick jackers sentence was perfectly fair it wasn't only one in four thought it was too harsh. sentence was perfectly fair. It wasn't only one in four thought it was too harsh. Another survey done by ITV, their World in Action Programme, found that 85% of the young people they asked thought that Mick Jagger deserved to go to prison. Some people may be surprised this into that, but to me that's not surprising at all because all the data we have about young people in the 60s suggests that they had very conservative attitudes towards social and cultural issues. I think also it's tied up with the sense of the stones as the embodiment of cool.
然而事实并非如此，因为当你查看当时的调查和民意测验时。几个月后的一项调查发现，大多数年轻人认为米克·贾格尔的判决非常公正，只有四分之一的人认为判决太严厉。判决非常公正。只有四分之一的人认为判决太严厉。独立电视台（ITV）旗下的“实际世界”节目进行的另一项调查发现，他们询问的年轻人中有百分之八十五认为米克·贾格尔罪有应得，应该去坐牢。有些人听到这个可能会感到惊讶，但对我来说这一点也不奇怪，因为我们掌握的关于六十年代年轻人的所有数据都表明，他们在社会和文化问题上持有非常保守的态度。我认为这也与人们将滚石乐队视为酷的化身这种感觉息息相关。
Because if you are not cool, your resentment and dislike of those who are cool is all the greater, wouldn't you say? Whereas William Rhys Mogg in his pinstripes doesn't have to worry about that. That's not an issue for him. Yeah. A lot of, do you think a lot of sort of suburban young people who are not part of the cool set don't go to university as most people don't, of course. They think, you know, they're having all this fun. Why should they have all this fun when I have no fun at all?
因为如果你不够酷，你对那些酷的人的怨恨和厌恶就会更大，你不这么认为吗？而威廉·里斯-莫格穿着细条纹西装，就不必担心这一点。这对不是什么问题。是的。很大一部分，你觉得许多不属于酷圈子的郊区年轻人，当然就像大多数人一样没有上过大学，他们会想，你知道，他们玩得这么开心。凭什么他们在毫无乐趣可言的时候能玩得这么开心？
Right. And again, I would imagine this, that the sense of the poshness of the house would play into that. Yeah, I think you might be right. You know, if you're in your mid twenties, the opportunities to own a house, let alone a 16th century house in Sussex, fairly limited I'd have thought. Tom, I don't want to give anything away, but I think if we saw some rival, very successful historians sent to prison for having too much fun, I mean, our WhatsApp group would be going
对的。而且再次我想象，这种房子的奢华感会在其中起作用。是的，我想你是对的。你知道，如果你正处于二十岁出头，拥有房子的机会，更不用说苏塞克斯郡十六世纪的房子了，我想机会相当有限。汤姆，我不想泄露任何机密，但我想如果我们看到一些竞争对手、非常成功的历史学家因为玩得太高兴而被送进监狱，我的意思是，我们的WhatsApp群肯定会
wild. No, you wouldn't. I would be sorry for them because I'm a nicer person than you. I get the force of your observation, Dominic. So anyway, Richard's conviction was overturned on appeal by Lord Chief Justice Parker at the end of July. Mick Jagger's conviction stood, but the original sentence was quashed. The prison sentence was considered much too harsh. And actually that very evening, this is such a 60s thing,
炸锅的。不，你不会的。我会为他们感到难过，因为我比你是个更好的人。我理解你的观察力，多米尼克。不管怎样，理查兹的定罪在七月底被首席大法官帕克在上诉时推翻了。米克·贾格尔的定罪维持不变，但原判被撤销了。刑期被认为太重了。事实上，就在当晚，这真是一件极具六十年代风格的事，
he went on a special talk show edition of World in Action with the combination of William Rees-Mogg at the Edge of the Times, the Bishop of Woolwich and Harold Wilson's first home secretary, Frank Soskis. And Jagger went on this program and he made a point of saying, I'm not a rebel. I really respect the post wartime generation. You know, I really so sad to see myself at the center of all this. And the Times had special praise for him the next day said he was articulate and thoughtful. He has much more grace of manner than one would have expected, which isn't me really not that surprising because as we said last time, he's a very bright grammar school boy who got into the London School of Economics when it was really hard to do
他参加了《实际世界》节目的特别脱口秀版，同台的有《泰晤士报》主编威廉·里斯-莫格、伍尔维奇主教和哈罗德·威尔逊的第一任内政大臣弗兰克·索斯基斯。贾格尔参加了这个节目，并特意表示：“我不是反叛者。我真的很尊重战后这一代人。你知道，看到自己成为这一切的中心，我真的感到很难过。”第二天，《泰晤士报》对他给予了特别赞扬，称他口齿伶俐、思维敏捷，“他的举止比人们预期的要优雅得多”，这其实对我来说并不算太奇怪，因为正如我们上次所说，他是一个非常聪明的文法学校男孩，在伦敦政治经济学院很难考入的时候考了进去。
so. And he judges his look perfectly. He looks cool, but it's not kind of aggressively 1967 kind of white suit, I think. It's sort of, yeah, exactly. Exactly. He's very well dressed. So there is one aspect. It appears that all's well that ends well, but this has not ended well for everybody because the third man of the case is this guy,
而且他对自己的外表把握得非常完美。他看起来很酷，但不是那种咄咄逼人的1967年式的白西装，我觉得。它有点，对，没错。对，没错。他穿得很好。所以有一个方面。看来皆大欢喜，但这对每个人来说都不是皆大欢喜，因为这个案子的第三个人是这个人，
the art dealer Robert Fraser, and his sentence was not overturned on appeal. And he spent four months in Wyrmwood Scrubs where he worked in the prison kitchens. And actually, if you read Harriet Viner's biography of him, Groovy Bob, there's some lovely letters from Jagger and Richards. They're very sweet, actually. They sort of say, oh, it was so worth thinking about you all the time. We'll have a really groovy time when you get out. They did love him. Yeah, they did.
艺术品商罗伯特·弗雷泽，他的定罪在上诉时没有被推翻。他在怀姆伍德斯克拉布斯监狱度过了四个月，在那里他在监狱厨房工作。事实上，如果你读哈丽雅特·瓦纳为他写的传记《时髦的鲍勃》，里面有一些贾格尔和理查兹写给他的可爱信件。其实它们非常甜蜜。他们大概是说，哦，一直想着你真是太值得了。等你出来后我们要过一段真正时髦的时光。他们确实很爱他。是的，他们确实爱他。
The Beatles liked him, didn't they? Yeah, he staged John Lennon's first art show. Yeah, they all really liked him. But he didn't have a groovy time, actually, when he got out. He became a complete nutter heroin addict. His gallery failed. He went off to India. He had a massive kind of drink and drugs hell and he ended up dying of AIDS in 1986.
披头士乐队喜欢他，对吧？是的，他筹办了约翰·列农的第一个画展。是的，他们都很喜欢他。但事实上，他出来后并没有过上时髦的生活。他成了彻底的疯狂海洛因瘾君子。他的画廊倒闭了。他去了印度。他陷入了酗酒和吸毒的巨大地狱，最终于1986年死于艾滋病。
So if you want a story that captures the darker side of the sixes, the casualties and so on, his is a really, really good example. And actually after the break, when we continue the Rolling Stones' story, this will get an awful lot darker and we will be looking a lot more at the lives destroyed by the excitement of the 60s in the second half. So join us in a few minutes and we will be painting it black. Now listen, will you just cool it for a minute? Because I would really like to say something for Brian. I'd really dig it if you would be with us. Just cool it. About how we feel about him just going when we didn't expect him to? Peace, peace. He is not dead. He doth not sleep. He hath awakened from the dream of life. Tis we who lost in stormy visions,
所以，如果你想要一个能捕捉到六十年代黑暗面、牺牲品等的故事，他的经历是一个非常非常好的例子。事实上，休息过后，当我们继续讲述滚石乐队的故事时，情况会变得非常黑暗，在下半部分中，我们将更多地关注那些被六十年代的兴奋所摧毁的生活。所以请在几分钟后加入我们，我们将涂黑它。现在听着，你能不能安静一会儿？因为我真的很想为布莱恩说点什么。如果你能和我们在一起，我会很高兴的。安静点。关于我们对他突然离开而我们没有预料到这点的感受？和平，和平。他没有死。他没有睡着。他从人生的梦境中醒来。是我们，迷失在风暴般的幻觉中，
keep with phantoms an unprofitable strife and in mad trance stripe with our spirit's knife in vulnerable nothings. We decay like corpses in a charnel. Fear and grief convulse us and consume us day by day and cold hopes swarm like worms within our living clay. Mick Jagger of course, reading Adonis, Shelley's Elegy on the Death of Keats. And he is there comparing John Keats to Brian Jones, who has just died and he's talking at Hyde Park Festival. I think that comparing Brian Jones to John Keats is flattering Brian Jones. I think it is. But we'll come to that.
用幻影进行着无利可图的争斗，在疯狂的恍惚中用灵魂之刀与脆弱的虚无搏斗。我们像阴暗墓穴中的尸体一样腐烂。恐惧和悲剧让我们痉挛，日复一日地吞噬着我们，寒冷的希望像蠕虫一样在我们活生生的血肉中群集。米克·贾格尔当然在朗读阿多尼斯，雪莱为济慈之死写的挽歌。他在那里把约翰·济慈与刚刚去世的布莱恩·琼斯进行对比，他正在海德公园艺术节上发言。我认为将布莱恩·琼斯与约翰·济慈进行对比是对布莱恩·琼斯的恭维。我认为是的。但我们会谈到这一点。
So Dominic, you mentioned the Hyde Park concert held on the 5th of July, 1969. At least a quarter of a million people gathered there to hear it as one of the Stones' two most famous concerts. But what gives it its fame and its resonance is the circumstance, the fact that that Brian Jones is found a member of the stones is dead. So what's the, what's, what's the backdrop there? Cause we haven't actually really mentioned Brian Jones up to now, cause he was not at the party.
所以多米尼克，你提到了1969年7月5日举行海德公园演唱会。至少有二十五万人聚集在那里倾听，这是滚石乐队最著名的两场演唱会之一。但让它成名并引起共鸣的是环境，是滚石乐队成员布莱恩·琼斯被发现死亡这一事实。那么背景是什么呢？因为我们之前实际上并没有真正提到布莱恩·琼斯，因为他没有去参加聚会。
He was not. And just before I get on to Brian Jones, Tom, I will once again congratulate you on a superb, a really superb impression. I enjoyed that very much. So yes, Brian Jones is, question, the founder of the Rolling Stones. If you listen to the first episode, you'll remember he places the advert. He puts the band together and at first he's effectively the manager. But from quite an early stage, the others have realized he is fragile.
他没有去。汤姆，在我继续讲布莱恩·琼斯之前，我要再次祝贺你模仿得非常出色，真的非常出色。我非常喜欢。所以，是的，布莱恩·琼斯是滚石乐队的创始人之疑。如果你听了第一集，你会记得他登了广告。他把乐队组建起来，一开始他实际上是经理。但从很早的时候起，其他人就意识到他很脆弱。
He's flaky. He's very demanding. He's hard to get on with. He crucially refuses to write his own songs because he just wants to basically do blues songs. So as early as 1963, he's been marginalised by Mick and Keith and Andrew Lou Goldham, their first manager. And over time, this has got much worse.
他很不靠谱。他要求很高。他很难相处。最关键的是，他拒绝自己写歌，因为他基本上只想唱布鲁斯歌曲。所以早在1963年，他就被米克、基思和他们的第一任经理安德鲁·卢·奥尔德姆边缘化了。随着时间的推移，这种情况变得更糟。
He has been torn between resenting Jagger and Richards and their fame and trying to suck up to them. And actually by the time they really become internationally famous, the others have come to really dislike him. I hate to laugh because he has a very tragic fate, but they're so horrible about him in their interviews. So Mick Jagger, normally the way their interviews work is that they always say, oh, we love Brian. Brian was wonderful. Such a shame about Brian. And then in the next sentence they will say, and I quote, he was an extremely difficult
他在怨恨贾格尔和理查兹以及他们的名气与试图巴结他们之间备受煎熬。事实上，当他们真正享誉国际时，其他人已经开始真正讨厌他了。我不愿笑，因为他有着非常悲惨的命运，但他们在采访中对他的评价实在是太糟糕了。所以米克·贾格尔，通常他们的采访方式是他们总是说，哦，我们爱布莱恩。布莱恩太棒了。布莱恩真是太可惜了。然后在下一句他们就会说，我引用，“他是一个极其困难
person. There was something very, very disturbed about him. He was a very paranoid personality. And my favorite one is by Ian Stewart, who had been their keyboardist, a Scotsman who was basically pushed out of the band. Guy with a massive chin. Massive chin. And then he became their kind of...
的人。他身上有一些非常非常不正常的东西。他是一个非常多疑的人。”我最喜欢的是伊恩·斯图尔特的评价，他曾是他们的键盘手，一个苏格兰人，基本上被赶出了乐队。下巴非常大的人。下巴非常大。然后他变成了他们的一种……
Kind of roadie, isn't he? Yeah, kind of roadie and a sort of stones whisperer who accompanied them on tour and stuff and was sort of the conscience of the band. He said of Brian Jones, he was a very difficult person. Nobody wanted to be in the same car with Brian for any length of time. And then my favourite line, I think in all history, being Welsh, he had a very obnoxious streak to him. Well, and that is one for our Welsh listeners who are always complaining that we never do
某种公路管理员，对吧？是的，某种公路管理员，也是某种随他们巡演等等的“滚石密友”，某种乐队的良心。他这样评价布莱恩·琼斯：“他是一个非常难相处的人。没有人愿意和布莱恩在同一辆车里待太久。”然后是我认为历史上最棒的一句台词，作为威尔士人，他身上有一股非常令人讨厌的特质。好吧，这对我们那些总是抱怨我们从不做的威尔士听众来说是一句名言
any Welsh history. So yes, I mean, it's important to emphasise this is an inter-Celtic disagreement here because this is a Scotsman book. Yeah, of course. So as Brian Jones has been forced out of the band, he ended up moving into this Muse cottage in Chelsea, had a string of girlfriends who he treated incredibly badly. I mean, there's always discussion about whether John Lennon treated women badly. Brian Jones is in a different league.
任何威尔士历史。所以，是的，我的意思是，强调这是一个凯尔特人内部的分歧很重要，因为这是一个苏格兰人……是的，当然。所以当布莱恩·琼斯被迫离开乐队后，他搬进了切尔西的这座小屋，交往了一连串的女朋友，他对这些女朋友极其残忍。我的意思是，总是有关于约翰·列农是否虐待女性的讨论。布莱恩·琼斯完全是另一个级别的。
I mean, he really does beat up his girlfriends. He's drinking at least a bottle of whiskey or brandy a day, swallowing handfuls of pills. The music press starts to notice that even at this point in 1965, he's disappearing and he becomes very sort of insecure. And then at the end of 1965, he meets this woman called Anita Pallenberg. Now she is groovy. She's an extraordinary person. So she's a West German model from a very, very wealthy, artistic German family. She'd studied art restoration and graphic design. She speaks four languages. She's obsessed with black magic. She sort of puts it about that she's a witch. She ends up, of course, a massive heroin
我的意思是，他确实殴打他的女朋友。他一天至少喝一瓶威士忌或白兰地，一把一把地吞药片。音乐界开始注意到，即使在1965年的这个时候，他也在消失，并变得非常没有安全感。然后在1965年底，他遇到了一个叫安妮塔·帕伦博格的女人。现在她很时髦。她是一个非凡的人。她是一个西德模特，来自一个非常非常富有、艺术气息浓厚的德国家庭。她学过艺术修复和平面设计。她会说四种语言。她痴迷于黑魔法。她四处散布自己是个巫婆。她最终当然成了一个巨大的海洛因
addict. And she and Brian have this very strange self-destructive relationship. Tons of drugs, putting on and off Nazi uniforms, sadomasochistic sessions, it's all happening and it reaches a sort of climax with this disastrous holiday they go on to Morocco with Keith Richards. So Keith's in the middle of the Redlands chaos and he wants to get away from the press and they say, oh come with us to Morocco. They drive off. I mean, it's a sign of how these works in the 60s. They didn't fly, they drive and they get across France and Brian Jones fell ill in Toulouse.
瘾君子。她和布莱恩有着非常奇怪的自我毁灭式的关系。大量的毒品，穿脱纳粹制服，性虐待狂式的聚会，这一切都在发生，并且随着他们与基思·理查兹一起去摩洛哥的那次灾难性的度假达到了某种高潮。所以基思正处于雷德兰兹混乱的中心，他想远离媒体，他们说，哦，跟我们一起去摩洛哥吧。他们开车出发。我的意思是，这标志着六十年代的工作方式。他们没有坐飞机，而是开车穿过法国，布莱恩·琼斯在图卢兹生病了。
Keith Richards and Anita said, well, we'll go on. You can catch us up. By the time he got to Marrakesh and he caught up with them, they'd started to have an affair and there's terrible tension. I mean, it's like the world's worst holiday. And eventually Brian Jones cracked and he beat her up really badly. And then he said, oh, I feel a bit bad about that. Why don't you, I'll make it up to you. Why don't we have an orgy with some local prostitutes? Because nothing says sorry like that. And Keith Richards at this point said, come on mate, enough's enough.
基思·理查兹和安妮塔说，好吧，我们先走。你可以赶上我们。等他到了马拉喀什赶上他们时，他们已经开始有染了，气氛极其紧张。我的意思是，这就像世界上最糟糕的假期。最终布莱恩·琼斯崩溃了，他把她狠狠地打了一顿。然后他说，哦，我对此感觉有点糟糕。你为什么不——我会弥补你的。我们为什么不和当地的妓女开个群交派对呢？因为没有什么比这更能表示道歉了。基思·理查兹此时说，得了吧伙计，够了。
And he drove her all the way back to London and left Brian Jones behind. And Jones took this incredibly badly. So he returned to Britain a complete wreck and he went around saying to people, they took my music, they took my band and now they've taken my love. It would be moving if he hadn't been beating her up. Keith Richards was very, do you want to read his line, Tom, in your excellent voice? Extra hassles between Brian and me because I took his old lady. You know, he enjoyed beating chicks up, not a likable guy.
他一路开车把她送回伦敦，把布莱恩·琼斯留在了后面。琼斯对此感到非常痛苦。所以他回到英国时已经成了一个废人，他到处对人说：“他们拿走了我的音乐，他们拿走了我的乐队，现在他们拿走了我的爱。”如果不是他一直在殴打她的话，这倒还挺感人的。基思·理查兹非常——汤姆，你想用你出色的声音读一下他的台词吗？“布莱恩和我之间有额外的摩擦，因为我抢了他的老太婆。你知道，他喜欢揍妞，不是一个讨人喜欢的人。”
I honestly don't think you'll find anyone who liked Brian. If something happened to me at the rest of his history and you, Theo and Tabby were saying stuff like that, Tom, I'd be gutted. I'd be absolutely gutted. I was worrying about the other way. Interesting. Anyway, his flat is always being raided in 1967 and 68 by the police. Actually this whole business about the establishment conspiracies.
老实说，我不认为你能找到任何喜欢布莱恩的人。如果我身上发生了什么事，剩下的就是历史了，而你、西奥和塔比在说这样的话，汤姆，我会心碎的。我绝对会心碎的。我一直在担心另一种情况。有趣。不管怎样，他的公寓在1967年和1968年一直遭到警察的搜查。事实上，所有关于建制派阴谋的这些事情。
So here, I think you have an example of why the establishment conspiracy stuff doesn't work. The magistrates are constantly kind of letting him off, he'll give him a sentence, then it's overturned on appeal. Is that because it's in, perhaps in London and they could just groove here in London? No, I don't think so. I think it's that they're genuinely not, they're sort of, the silly stereotype, which is, oh, they're just hatchet faced old men. It's just not true. They're sensible, decent, you know, of course they're small C conservative people, but they're not monsters and they don't, they don't hate young people and they don't probably even hate the
所以在这里，我认为你有一个例子，说明为什么建制派阴谋论行不通。地方法官不断地放过他，判他一个刑期，然后上诉时就被推翻了。这是因为在伦敦，也许在伦敦他们就能尽情享乐吗？不，我不这么认为。我认为他们真的不是，他们是那种，愚蠢的刻板印象，哦，他们只是一群面目可憎的老头子。这根本不是真的。他们是明智的、正派的，你知道，当然他们是小c保守派，但他们不是怪物，他们不，他们可能甚至不讨厌年轻人，甚至可能不讨厌
Rolling Stones, a lot of them. But the judge at the Redlands trial. Yeah, but that's the Horsham Plowing Agricultural Society for you, Tom. Exactly. Well, that's my point. It's the difference between Chelsea and Horsham. I'm not sure about that. I mean, no offense to Chelsea and Horsham. I'm not sure about that. I mean, no offense to anyone in Horsham. I'm talking about the 60s.
滚石乐队，有很多。但雷德兰兹审判的法官。对，但这就是霍舍姆犁地农业协会的风格，汤姆。没错。好吧，这就是我的观点。这就是切尔西和霍舍姆的区别。我对这一点不太确定。我是说，对切尔西和霍舍姆没有恶意。我对这一点不太确定。我是说，对霍舍姆的任何人没有恶意。我在说60年代。
Yeah, I'm not sure about that. I think that's, I think by and large, you know, there are always sort of parodic daily express reading magistrates, but also there are a lot who want. And actually in his case, he always gets psychiatrists and therapists and things to testify on his behalf to say quite reasonably, this bloke is on the edge of something you know he's incredibly flaky prison will probably kill him and actually the magicians are quite sympathetic so sixty eight when he's up at the front of the same people the same panel they said to him. You know again really and they gave him a small fire and they said the third time you really will have to go to prison, but you have to kind of be more sensible. So he then went off to Morocco and hung around in Morocco. So while he's off in Morocco, the Stones are trying to reboot themselves. So in late 67, early 68, they had reached their nadir with their Satanic Majesties Request, which was this record. Do you think?
是的，我对这一点不太确定。我觉得那是，我觉得总的来说，你知道，总是有些那种讽刺性的、读《每日快报》的治安法官，但也有很多人想。实际上在案子中，他总是找精神病学家、治疗师之类的人为他出庭作证，很合理地表示：这家伙已经到了某种边缘，你知道，他极其不可靠，坐牢可能会要了他的命，而法官其实挺同情的。所以在68年，当他在同一批人、同一个小组面前受审时，他们对他说：你知道，真的又来了。他们罚了他一小笔钱，说第三次你们可真的得进监狱了，但你们得稍微懂事点。于是他去了摩洛哥，在摩洛哥晃悠。所以在他在摩洛哥期间，滚石乐队正试图重整旗鼓。所以在67年末、68年初，他们凭借《撒旦陛下的请求》这张唱片跌入了谷底，就是这张唱片。你觉得呢？
I think so. Do you like that? It's not a great album, but it does have one brilliant track, We Love You, where they take the piss out of the trial and they model it on Oscar Wilde. So Mick is Oscar Wilde, Keith is the High Court Judge and Marianne Faithfull is a frankly sensational Bozy. She kind of looks like a cross between Twiggy and Alfred uh, and, and Alfred Douglas, amazing look.
我也这么觉得。你喜欢这个吗？这不是一张伟大的专辑，但它确实有一首精彩的歌，叫《我们爱你》，他们在歌里嘲弄了那场审判，并以王尔德为原型进行了创作。所以米克是王尔德，基思是高等法院法官，玛丽安·费思福则坦率地说是个惊艳的波齐（Bosie）。她看起来有点像崔姬（Twiggy）和阿尔弗雷德·道格拉斯的结合体，这造型绝了。
But Tom, this is, I mean, you like dressing. I mean, you're a fan of dressing up. You've done it on occasion for the podcast. You're basically giving it marks for dressing up rather than for musical merit and music and, and swagger. There's a great visual joke where there's a fur rug and Marianne Faithfull lifts up the fur rug to reveal Mick. Oh, great banter.
但是汤姆，这个，我是说，你喜欢穿搭。我是说，你是盛装打扮的狂热爱好者。你为这个播客偶尔也这么做过。你基本上是在为服装打分，而不是为音乐本身的价值、音乐以及风度打分。这里有个很棒的视觉笑话，有一块毛皮地毯，玛丽安·费思福掀开毛皮地毯露出了米克。哦，太棒了。
And also the other thing about that particular track is that it has a very good mellotron in it and that is played by Brian and it's his, I think his last kind of contribution. Where you see this is, you and I looking for different things than Rolling Stones. I'm looking for sort of sassannic simplicity and you're looking for whimsy and humor. No, I'm not. I'm not. I'm responding to the full range of their oeuvre. Oh, you. Okay.
而且关于那首歌的另一件事是，里面有一个非常棒的梅洛特朗电子琴，那是布莱恩弹的，这大概是他最后的某种贡献。你看，你和我对滚石乐队的期待是不一样的。我在寻找某种撒旦式的纯粹，而你在寻找异想天开和幽默。不，我不是。我不是。我在回应他们全部的作品范围。哦，你。好吧。
See, I like the fact that they are this they released this and everybody says it's it's abject. It gets terrible reviews. It's a complete Beatles ripoff and there's too many kind of stuff we play backwards and people laughing uncontrollably. And actually, come on, get back to your old stuff. And then they start working on the kind of blues roots stuff that becomes beggars banquet. So this is the album that has Street Fighting Man and sympathy for the devil. And it's more aggressive and it's more hard edged and it's more the rolling stones that everybody
你看，我喜欢他们这一点，他们发布了这个，然后每个人都说这简直糟透了。评价极差。这完全是抄袭披头士，里面有太多我们倒着放的音乐，人们还无法控制地大笑。实际上，得了吧，回到你们以前的风格去吧。然后他们开始创作那种蓝调根源风格的东西，后来成了《乞丐盛宴》。所以这张专辑里有《街头斗士》和《对恶魔的同情》。它更具攻击性，更硬派，也更像是每个人想要的那个滚石乐队。
that everybody wants. So Brian Jones makes virtually no contribution to this at all because he's so off his face on drugs. And they just start on a new album in 1969 called Let It Bleed, which he basically doesn't really turn up for. It kicks off with Gimmie Shelter, doesn't it? Yeah. So they have already started to think he's got to go and they're working with a replacement who's called Mick Taylor, who is from a band
每个人都想要的。所以布莱恩·琼斯对这张专辑几乎没有任何贡献，因为他吸毒吸得神志不清。他们在1969年开始录制一张新专辑叫《让它流血》，基本上他根本没怎么露面。专辑是从《给我避难所》开始的，对吧？是的。所以他们已经开始觉得他必须得走了，他们正在和一个叫米克·泰勒的接替者合作，米克·泰勒来自一个叫约翰·梅尔蓝调破坏者的乐队。
called John Mayall's Blues Breakers. A lot of people will know that the Rolling Stones got into terrible trouble with their taxes. And the real issue with them is they discovered that their finances had been ill-managed and they hadn't paid enough tax during the 1960s. And they are going to face colossal tax and legal bills. And to make money, they need to go on tour to America. But Brian Jones has two drugs convictions and he almost certainly will be refused entry. And frankly, even if he got in, he will be useless because he can't play publicly.
叫约翰·梅尔蓝调破坏者。很多人都知道，滚石乐队陷入了可怕的税务麻烦。他们面临的真正问题是，他们发现自己的财务管理不善，在20th世纪60年代没有缴纳足够的税款。他们将面临巨额的税务和法律账单。为了赚钱，他们需要去美国巡演。但布莱恩·琼斯有两次毒品定罪，他几乎肯定会被拒绝入境。坦白说，即使他进去了也没用，因为他无法公开演出。
frankly, even if he got in, he will be useless because he can't play publicly. So in June, 1968, the 8th of June, Mick Jagger, Keith Richards and Charlie Watts drove to Cotchford Farm, formerly AA Milne's house, to break the bad news. And they literally break it to him surrounded by Winnie the Pooh memorabilia. Hush, hush, whisper who dares. A sort of blank faced eeyore looking over at them, whatever. And it's a terrible scene. Like he pretends he's happy and they say, well, we'll put out a statement that it's musical differences.
坦白说，即使他进去了也没用，因为他无法公开演出。所以在1968年6月，6月8日，米克·贾格尔、基思·理查兹和查理·沃茨开车前往科奇福德农场——这里曾是A·A·米恩的住宅——去向他宣布这个坏消息。他们在一堆小熊维尼的纪念品包围中，直言不讳地把消息告诉了他。嘘，嘘，轻声慢语，谁敢打听。一张面无表情的驴子伊娥正看着他们，诸如此类。这真是一个糟糕的场面。他假装很高兴，而他们说，好吧，我们会发表一份声明，说这是音乐理念不合。
Mick Jagger said afterwards, it was difficult, but not as difficult as I thought. So they do it quite coldly. There were different accounts of how he spent his final weeks, whether he was, some people say he was inconsolable, shocked, they were shocked at the sight of him. He was frail and downcast. Other people visited him and he was said, they found him upbeat talking about new band and stuff. Possibly this is the effect of the drugs, that his moods are all over the place.
米克·贾格尔事后说，这很难，但没有我想象的那么难。所以他们做得很冷血。关于他最后几周是怎么度过的，有不同的说法。有人说他悲痛欲绝、震惊不已，他们看到他的样子都惊呆了，他虚弱而沮丧。其他人去看望他时，发现他情绪高涨，还在谈论新乐队之类的事情。这可能是毒品的作用，导致他的情绪起伏不定。
And then on the 2nd of July, 1969, it was a lovely warm day. He's got a new girlfriend called Anna Voellin who's Swedish. And they're spending their time hanging out by a swimming pool. He's got terrible asthma, Brian Jones. So he's always taking his inhaler. He's got a lovely stripy blue t-shirt, hasn't he? He does. He loves a Breton.
然后到了1969年7月2日，那是个可爱暖和的日子。他有一个新女友叫安娜·沃林，是个瑞典人。他们把时间都花在泳池边闲逛上。布莱恩·琼斯有严重的哮喘，所以他总是在用吸入器。他穿着一件可爱的蓝色条纹T恤，对吧？是的。他特别喜欢不列颠水手衫。
That's a Breton t-shirt. And late that night, they hang around at the swimming pool with a bloke called Frank Thorogood, who was doing building work for Jones on the farm. See, that sounds sinister, doesn't it? Do you think so? Yeah, I do. Generally, in these kinds of dramas where there are, you know, somebody's doing the building. Yeah. Why is he there in the evening? That's the question. They're drinking loads of vodka
那是件不列颠水手衫。那天深夜，他们和几个叫弗兰克·索罗古德的家伙在泳池边闲晃，这人当时正在为琼斯农场的建筑工程干活。听起来挺阴险的，对吧？你这么觉得吗？是的，我确实这么觉得。通常在这种类型的戏剧里，当有人在搞建筑工程……对啊。他为什么大晚上还在那儿？这就是问题所在。他们喝了大量的伏特加，
and taking amphetamines, and then they decide to have a swim at around midnight. Frank Thorogood and the others get out of the pool and go inside, leaving Brian in the pool and when they return Tom, Brian is dead. He's floating lifeless in the pool. So they called an ambulance and whatnot and the police, police pathologist said he's full of drink drinking drugs. Coroner said he's obviously drowned because he's off his face on, on drinking drugs. However, the suspicion of murder, murder has hung over this. If you go on the internet, there are demented conspiracy theories. I mean, the two best ones are one killed by the mafia, presumably using the same team that killed Kennedy in Dallas in 1963 and that the other Rolling Stones killed him.
还服用了安非他命，然后他们决定在午夜左右去游泳。弗兰克·索罗古德和其他人从泳池里出来进了屋，把布莱恩留在泳池里。当他们回来时，汤姆，布莱恩已经死了。他毫无生气地漂在泳池里。于是他们叫了救护车之类的，警察法医说他体内全是酒精和药物。法官说他显然是淹死的，因为他喝了酒又吸了毒，已经神志不清了。然而，谋杀的嫌疑一直笼罩着这件事。如果你上网看，会有各种疯狂的阴谋论。我的意思是，其中最好的两个流言是：一个是说被黑手党杀了，用的估计是1963年在达拉斯刺杀肯尼迪的同一伙人；另一个是说被其他滚石乐队成员杀了。
It seems unlikely to me actually, improbable. So in the 2000s, the started to become allegations. You can find them very easily. They're in Anna Voellens own book, the girlfriend's book, The Murder of Brian Jones, that the builder used, you had, you identified him from the beginning, Tom. I did. I fingered him.
在我看来这似乎不太可能，很不真实。所以在2000年代，开始出现各种指控。你很容易就能找到它们。它们就写在安娜·沃林自己的书里，也就是那个女友的书《布莱恩·琼斯的谋杀案》中，说是那个建筑工干的，你从一开始就认出他来了，汤姆。是的。我指认了他。
Frank Thorogood. You're safe from being sued by him because he died in 1993. And it is said that on his deathbed, he made a confession that he had killed Jones. So you're sticking to that, are you? No, I'm floating it out, but I'm saying that this is probably what would happen if this were a Sunday evening detective drama. Like Bergerac? No, not Bergerac. Bergerac is brilliant, you can't be dissing Bergerac on this show. No, what's it? The one where they're always killing each other, the village. Midsomer Murders. Midsomer Murders. Midsomer Murders,
弗兰克·索罗古德。你不用担心被他起诉，因为他在1993年就去世了。据说他在临终前做出了供认，承认是自己杀了琼斯。所以你坚持这种看法咯？不，我只是把它抛出来，但我想说的是，如果这是一部周日晚上的侦探剧，这大概就是情节走向。像《伯热拉克》？不，不是《伯热拉克》。《伯热拉克》很棒，你不能在这个节目里贬低《伯热拉克》。那是什么？就是那个他们一直在互相谋杀的村庄。麦镇谋杀案。米德索默谋杀案。米德索默谋杀案，
it makes a brilliant addition to Midsomer Murders. Yeah. Well anyway, Charlie Watts doesn't think that, he despises, I don't know what he thinks about or he thought about Midsummer murders. He'd had loved it. He'd have stayed in on a Sunday night. He would actually. Cup of cocoa, settled down. He'd have loved it. He'd have watched the Antiques Roadshow first and then he'd have watched Midsummer. He'd have actually exhibited stuff on the Antiques Roadshow, given the chance, I imagine. Yeah. He'd have lent his house as a set. Exactly. Well, Bill Wyman with a metal detector. Remember Bill Wyman, we used to go around in a metal. Exactly. Well, Bill Wyman with a metal detector. Remember Bill Wyman, we used to go around in the metal, maybe still does, with the metal detector detecting things.
它为《米德索默谋杀案》提供了一个极好的素材。好吧，不管怎样，查理·沃茨可不这么认为，他鄙视……我不知道他对《米德索默谋杀案》是怎么看的。他本来会很喜欢的。他周日晚上会宅在家里看。他确实会。喝着热可可，安顿下来。他会很喜欢的。他会先看《古董巡回秀》，然后看《米德索默》。如果有机会的话，我想他甚至会在《古董巡回秀》上展出自己的藏品呢。对。他会把自己的房子借出去当片场。没错。还有带着金属探测器的比尔·维曼。还记得比尔·维曼吗，我们以前带着金属探测器到处转。没错。还有带着金属探测器的比尔·维曼。还记得比尔·维曼吗，我们以前带着金属探测器到处转，可能现在还在到处检测东西呢。
I mean, there's another side to Bill Wyman's life, which we don't need to go into. But well, all of them. Charlie Watts said, all that about Brian being knocked off is rubbish. I know a lot of people, this is the next line is classic Rolling Stones interview. I know a lot of people who would have willingly knocked him off, but it didn't happen. Slightly of disappointment about that. I think.
我是说，比尔·维曼的生活还有另一面，我们没必要深入探讨。不过呢，他们所有人都是。查理·沃茨说，什么布莱恩被做掉的全都是废话。我知道很多人——接下来这句是典型的滚石乐队式的采访——我知道有很多人很乐意把他做掉，但这事没发生。对此多少有点失望，我想。
Yeah. Charlie Watts said his pool was too hot. Whenever you got there, it used to shimmer with heat. You would drive down there on a spring morning and the heat would be rising off the top, so it was too hot and that's what killed him according to Charlie Watts. Right. Well, I probably, probably accurate. Yeah.
对。查理·沃茨说他的泳池太热了。你每次去那儿，泳池都热得直泛热浪。你在一个春天的早晨开车过去，热气会从水面上升腾起来，所以水温太高了，据查理·沃茨说，这就是害死他的原因。好吧。嗯，可能，可能挺准确的。对。
Well, maybe. He doesn't sound, I mean, clearly he was very, very ill and not treating his illness in a sensible way. Exactly. I think that's exactly right. Now the, the Rolling Stones had already made a plan to have this concert at Hyde Park on the Saturday, the 5th of July for the maximum publicity to unveil his replacement Mick Taylor. So they were going to have this free concert and the
好吧，也许吧。听起来他，显然他当时病得非常非常重，而且没有以理智的方式对待自己的病情。没错。我觉得完全正确。现在，滚石乐队已经计划好在7月5日星期六在海德公园举办这场音乐会，以获取最大的轰动效应，并揭幕他的替代者米克·泰勒。所以他们原本打算办这场免费音乐会，并且
arrangements had already been made. A special souvenir edition of the London Evening Standard, six different TV crews, they were going to be transported to the stage from their hotel in an armoured personnel carrier. Mick Jagger had already ordered his outfit from the boutique Mr. Fish. And what an outfit it is. And what an outfit. And they didn't want to scrap it. And so Charlie Watts said, let's turn it into a memorial to Brian. And so it is that on the 5th of July, this great 1960s set piece at Hyde Park, there are somewhere between a quarter and half a million people. And it is actually a lovely scene.
各项筹备工作都已经做好了。《伦敦标准晚报》的特别纪念版，六个不同的电视摄制组，他们将乘坐装甲运兵车从酒店被送到舞台。米克·贾格尔已经从“Mr. Fish”精品店订购了他的演出服。那真是一套绝妙的衣服。真是绝了。而且他们不想取消。于是查理·沃茨说，把它变成对布莱恩的纪念吧。于是就有了7月5日海德公园这场60年代的宏大场面，现场大约有四分之一到五十万观众。这其实是一个温馨的场景。
There's no trouble at all. It's a beautiful day. There are lots of people in caftans. They're all eating ice creams by the serpentine. The police are kind of chuckling and, you know, posing for photos or whatever. Now there are in a sign of things to come, 50 Hells Angels who have been hired to protect the equipment. But, you know, they get on all right with the crowd. It's all fine. Now there are, in a sign of things to come, 50 Hells Angels who have been hired to protect the equipment. But you know, they get on all right with the crowd, it's all fine. The concert
现场一点儿乱子也没有。天气晴朗。许多人都穿着长袍。大家都在蛇形湖畔吃冰淇淋。警察们也乐呵呵的，摆姿势拍照之类的。现在，有50名地狱天使被雇来保护设备，这也预示了未来的某些隐患。不过，他们和人群相处得还不错，一切都很好。现在，有50名地狱天使被雇来保护设备，这也预示了未来的某些隐患。不过，他们和人群相处得还不错，一切都很好。音乐会
starts at one o'clock, various warm-up acts, and then at four o'clock the Stones finally appear and Tom there is a bombshell as Mick Jagger unveils this long-awaited outfit that he's had specially made by Mr Fish. And Philip Norman, the Stones' biographer, says, whatever the audience were expecting, no one could have expected him to take the stage in lipstick, rouge and eye shadow and wearing a white frilly garment which for all the white vest and bell bottoms visible beneath still resembled nothing so much as a little girl's party dress. It's an amazing moment, isn't it?
在一点钟开始，有各种暖场表演，然后到四点钟滚石乐队终于登场了。汤姆，当米克·贾格尔揭晓他特意请“Mr. Fish”定制的期待已久的演出服时，全场震惊了。滚石乐队的传记作家菲利普·诺曼说：无论观众期待的是什么，没有人能料到他会涂着口红、胭脂、眼影，穿着一件白色荷叶边服装走上舞台，即便透过白背心和喇叭裤看过去，它看起来依然跟一个小女孩的派对裙没什么两样。这真是个惊人的时刻，对吧？
It is. Because it's the first time this has really happened. Well, it's surely up there with Gene Shrimpton's appearance at the Battle of Melbourne as one of the great turning points in world history. It's up there with the Cressi, isn't it? The Battle of Cressi. The Battle of Melbourne. And what was the other one we said? Wolves inventing Europe in the 1950s. Now I think you said that. Yeah. But I mean, it's definitely up there with, with decisive moments.
确实如此。因为这是此类事情真正第一次发生。好吧，这绝对可以和珍妮·什里姆顿（Jean Shrimpton）在墨尔本赛马会上的亮相并称为世界历史上的伟大转折点之一。它能跟克雷西战役相提并论，对吧？克雷西战役。墨尔本赛马会。我们刚才说另一个是什么来着？50年代沃尔夫发明了欧洲。现在我觉得你这是胡扯。对。但我的意思是，它绝对可以和那些决定性的时刻相提并论。
Well, on the rest is history. We only do the very, very biggest and most important historical moments, don't we? And actually, so he's also got a crucifix and a kind of dog collar, leather dog collar. And your reading, eccentric as it was, was too good because if you watch him on YouTube, Yeah, he's worse, isn't he? His reading of Shelley, it actually improves a bit. It does get better as he gets in, but when he starts, he's clearly, I mean, God, he's quite young, you know, they're in their twenties. Quarter of a million people.
好吧，在《历史其余部分》播客中，我们只探讨最大、最重要的历史时刻，对吧？而且实际上，他还戴着一个十字架和一个类似狗项圈的东西，皮质狗项圈。你对雪莱诗歌的解读，虽然古怪，但效果出奇地好，因为如果你在YouTube上看他……对，他表现得更糟糕了，对吧？他读雪莱其实稍微有那么一点进步。随着他进入状态确实变好了，但他刚开始的时候明显，天哪，他当时还很年轻，你知道吧，他们才二十多岁。二十五万观众。
It's a bizarre situation to be in. He's clearly very nervous and he makes a dreadful mess of it. So he's getting all the words wrong and stumbling and stuff and all of this. However, the press coverage was bonkers. The Observer, from far off, you might have supposed that this great gathering had come to hear a famed religious leader or some Eastern mystic. At the end, they release all these butterflies. They're dead, aren't they? They got terrible complaints. The butterflies had all suffocated in the boxes. Disastrous.
身处这种状况实在太诡异了。他显然非常紧张，结果把事情搞得一团糟。他把所有的词都念错了，结结巴巴的，诸如此类。不过，媒体的报道简直疯狂。《观察家报》写道：远远望去，你可能会以为这场盛大聚会是来听某位著名的宗教领袖或某种东方神秘主义者的演讲。最后，他们放飞了所有的蝴蝶。它们都死了，对吧？引发了可怕的抱怨。蝴蝶在盒子里全都窒息了。太惨了。
The concert itself was very bad by all accounts. They're all very nervous. Mick Taylor is making his debut. He's terrified. However, as a public spectacle, a huge occasion, a great success. And as with every great 60s occasion, a mad column afterwards in the Guardian. So Richard got, he's a KGB agent, isn't he? He was a KGB agent of influence, I believe.
从各方面的反馈来看，音乐会本身非常糟糕。大家都非常紧张。米克·泰勒迎来了他的首秀，吓得要死。不过，作为一个公开奇观、一场盛大的活动，它取得了巨大的成功。而且就像每一个60年代的盛大活动一样，卫报随后刊登了一篇疯狂的专栏文章。理查德·戈特，他是个克格勃特工，对吧？我相信他曾是个克格勃的影响力特工。
He gave my first book, never had it so good, a disabiding review. Okay. Well, let's diss him. There wasn't enough about the Cuban revolution in it. And people in Britain cared about nothing so much as the Cuban revolution. He didn't dig your insistence on washing machines. No, he said, what's all this nonsense about people going to garden centers and Kingsley Amis? I want the Cuban revolution.
他给我的第一本书《好日子一去不复返》写了一篇极为苛刻的评论。好吧。那我们就贬低他一下。里面关于古巴革命的内容不够多。而英国人最关心的莫过于古巴革命了。他不买账你对洗衣机的执着。不，他说，人们去园艺中心和金斯利·艾米斯这算什么废话。我要的是古巴革命。
Anyway, he said of this concert, it was a great and epoch making event in British social history. Anyone who wants to understand the present political malaise in Britain or who wants to have an inkling what Britain will be like in 10 years time, should have been at the park on Saturday, he said. And of course, when you do the maths, 10 years on from this concept is almost exactly the point when Margaret Thatcher became Prime Minister. So a prediction that did not work out exactly as he anticipated. Well the Stones are not in favour of high taxes.
总之，他关于这场音乐会的评价是：这是英国社会史上一个伟大而划时代事件。任何想要理解英国当前政治混乱的人，或者想要预知英国10年后面貌的人，都应该去现场参加周六的公园音乐会，他说道。当然，如果你算一下，从这场音乐会过去10年，几乎正是玛格丽特·撒切尔成为首相的时间点。所以这是一个并没有完全按他预料那样实现的预测。好吧，滚石乐队可不支持高税收。
No. And Mrs Thatcher was also not in favor of high taxes. So in a sense you could say that the Stones decision to leave Britain and go to France is a prefiguring of the Thatcherite tax cutting regime. Because actually it's just after this concert that their tax advisor who is a I believe a Bavarian aristocrat called Prince Rupert Lüvenstein who didn't like their music, had never heard of them before they took him on but was brilliant at taxes. He said to them, you need to get out of Britain. You have been very poorly advised. You've been underpaying tax for years. The only way you can basically escape this
没有。撒切尔夫人其实也不支持高税收。所以在某种意义上，你可以说滚石乐队决定离开英国去法国，可以说是撒切尔主义减税制度的预演。因为实际上就在这次演唱会之后，他们的税务顾问——据我所知是一位名叫鲁珀特·吕文斯坦亲王的巴伐利亚贵族，他并不喜欢他们的音乐，在雇他之前甚至没听说过他们，但他在税务方面却是个天才。他对他们说，你们得离开英国。你们之前的税务建议太糟了。你们多年来一直在少交税。你们基本上能逃脱这一困境的唯一方法
and not be completely bankrupt is to get out of the country for two years non-resident and that means they go to France. But of course they still need to make money and so in October they fly to America for their first tour since the summer of 1966. And actually when they get to America at the end of 1969, they are young but they're not politically naive. They can tell that something has changed in the atmosphere. So listeners will remember ourica in nineteen sixty eight series with moved on less than a year since the end of that nixon's election. Keith richards said afterwards he said when we went to america before it was walt disney hamburger dates when you came back in nineteen sixty nine. It wasn't anymore it's darker they've had riots they've had v. Just the atmosphere feels, everything just feels more conflicted.
并且不至于彻底破产，那就是离开这个国家两年，成为非税务居民，这意味着他们得去法国。但当然，他们仍然需要赚钱，所以在十月，他们飞往美国，进行自1966年夏天以来的首次巡演。事实上，当他们在1969年底到达美国时，他们虽然年轻，但并不是政治上的白痴。他们能感觉到气氛发生了变化。所以听众们会记得我们在1968年的系列节目中讲过，距离尼克松当选还不到一年。基思·理查兹后来谈到时说，他说我们以前去美国时，那是华特迪士尼和汉堡约会，而当你1969年回来时，情况就不一样了，气氛更黑暗了，发生了暴乱，还有越南战争。整个气氛感觉，一切都感觉更加充满了冲突。
And you know, even the gigs, there was much less screaming than there was. There aren't teeny boppers there. Their fans seem older. And they comment on it. Charlie Watts, people didn't scream anymore. The music was taken seriously. Mick Jagger, he said the real surprise was that people actually listened to the music. But presumably they are older. I mean the teeny boppers have grown up. Exactly. And the tickets are also much more expensive.
你知道，甚至连演出也是如此，尖叫声比以前少多了。现场没有那么多十几岁的追星族了。他们的粉丝看起来更年长了。他们也注意到了这一点。查理·沃茨说，人们不再尖叫了。音乐受到了认真的对待。米克·贾格尔说，真正的惊奇在于人们真的在听音乐。但据推测他们确实年龄更大了。我是说那些十几岁的追星族已经长大了。确实如此。而且门票也贵得多。
This is the first rock tour, I think, where there were a lot of complaints about the prices of the tickets. Of course, they're charging as much as they can at this point because they're desperate for money because of their tax in Brolio. But also they can because both they and the fans have grown up. And I think this is actually part of a much bigger cultural shift that we often forget about because right up to this point, when people talked about the Rolling Stones, the phrase they used to describe them was a pop group. They never called them a rock group.
这是第一场摇滚巡演，我想，大家对票价有很多抱怨。当然，他们在此时尽可能地多收钱，因为由于税务纠纷，他们极度缺钱。但他们也能这样做，因为他们和粉丝都长大了。我认为这实际上是一个更大文化转变的一部分，而这个转变我们常常会忘记，因为直到这个时候，当人们谈论滚石乐队时，他们用来描述他们的词是“流行乐队”（pop group）。他们从来不称他们为“摇滚乐队”（rock group）。
They called them a pop group. They never called them a rock group, they called them a pop group. I think it's this point, 1967-69, that effectively rock music is invented as something serious and grown up and not teenage and not trivial. I think they are absolutely the centre of this and I think there are three elements to it. One is that cultural shift that we just mentioned, the shift from the kind of hippie-dippie flower power, everything is fun and sweet and sunny, to the darkness of the kind of Nixon years, which seems to, just seems the perfect match to a move from kind of pop to rock, to something a little bit more conflicted and a bit heavy and a bit more serious. The musicians themselves, the second thing, they are much older.
他们称他们为流行乐队。他们从来不称他们为摇滚乐队，他们称他们为流行乐队。我认为正是在1967至1969年这个时期，摇滚乐才真正作为一种严肃的、成熟的、而非针对青少年的、非琐碎的事物被发明出来。我认为他们绝对是这一切的核心，并且我认为其中有三个要素。首先是我们刚刚提到的那个文化转变，从那种嬉皮士式的、充满花朵力量的、一切都快乐甜蜜而阳光的氛围，转变为尼克松时代那种黑暗的基调，这似乎与从流行乐向摇滚乐的转变完美契合，转向了一种更加充满冲突、更加厚重、更加严肃的东西。音乐家本身，这是第二点，他们年龄大得多了。
You know, they're in their late twenties coming into their thirties. They no longer want to be pop stars. They want to be serious musicians. So you have people like Eric Clapton or Jimmy Page or Jeff Beck or whatever, who pride themselves on being kind of guitar virtuosos. I'm not just, I don't want people to scream. I want people to listen to the music. So there's a kind of an earnestness to it. And then the third thing, probably the most important thing, the market has changed. So if you're 16 in 1963 at the dawn of the
你知道，他们二十代末期快要三十岁了。他们不再想当流行歌星。他们想成为严肃的音乐家。所以你会看到像埃里克·克莱普顿、吉米·佩奇或杰夫·贝克这样的人，他们以自己作为某种吉他大师而自豪。我不只是，我不想让人们尖叫。我想让人们听音乐。所以这里面有一种认真态度。然后第三点，可能也是最重要的一点，市场变了。所以在1963年流行革命曙光初现时如果你是16岁的话，
kind of pop revolution, what are you? You're in your mid twenties now. And given what we know about the social structure at the time, you're almost certainly married and you almost certainly have a job. So there is a self-consciously adult market who don't want music anymore to dance to, which was the main point of music at the beginning of the sixties. They wanted to actually listen to the lyrics, which people didn't do. Which they might start printing on the back of the album, like with Sgt Pepper. Exactly, which they print on the back of the album, like with Sgt Pepper. Exactly, which they print on the back of the album. And it's at this point, the singles market goes into a long-term decline and the album market begins to surge and albums are
你现在是什么样的人？你现在二十五岁左右了。鉴于我们所了解的当时的社会结构，你几乎肯定已经结婚了，而且几乎肯定有工作。所以这是一个有着自我意识的成年人市场，他们不再需要伴舞的音乐——这是六十年代初期音乐的主要功能。他们实际上想要倾听歌词，这是以前人们不会做的事情。他们甚至可能会把歌词印在专辑封套的背面，就像《佩珀军士》那样。没错，就像他们把歌词印在专辑背面那样，就像《佩珀军士》一样。没错，就像他们把歌词印在背面一样。正是在这个时候，单曲市场陷入了长期衰退，而专辑市场开始飙升，专辑变得
much more profitable. So it makes sense now for bands, they start to call themselves bands rather than groups. And it makes sense for them to cater to these older listeners. So you get a band like Led Zeppelin, who emerged at this point. They don't bother with the singles market at all. They just want to make albums largely for slightly older listeners who actually aren't the teenage girls who have powered this at the very beginning. There's a brilliant discussion of this in a book by Charlie Gillick called The Sound of the City.
利润丰厚得多。所以现在对乐队来说合乎逻辑的是，他们开始称自己为乐队（bands）而不是组合（groups）。迎合这些年龄稍长的听众对他们来说很有意义。于是你有了像齐柏林飞艇这样在这个时期崛起的乐队。他们完全不理会单曲市场。他们只想制作主要面向稍微年长听众的专辑，而这些听众其实已经不再是当初在最初阶段推波助澜的那些十几岁的女孩了。查理·吉利克在一本名为《城市之声》的书中有过对此的精彩讨论。
And he talks about what a contrived and artificial sort of cleavage it is between pop and rock. But we're now so used to it, we've fallen for the PR basically, because it's about ultimately about working out how to sell more records. Older people won't buy music that they think is for teenagers. So this is the way you basically say no, it's not, it's a whole new genre. And that's how they do it. Anyway, let's end the episode, this enormous episode,
他谈到了流行乐和摇滚乐之间那种人为的、虚假的裂痕。但我们现在已经习以为常了，基本上是被公关说辞给忽悠了，因为这归根结底是为了研究如何卖出更多的唱片。年长的人不会购买他们认为是给十几岁年轻人听的音乐。所以这就是你基本上说“不，不是这样的，这是一个全新的流派”的方式。他们就是这样做的。不管怎样，让我们结束这一集，这一极其漫长的一集，
and indeed the story of the Stones in the 60s with the final act of that American tour. So all through this tour they have had massive criticism for their high ticket prices and they decide because they're kindly people that they will end with another free concert like Hyde Park and they say let's do it in San Francisco in the city of the counterculture. We'll have a little festival. We'll get the Grateful Dead and Jefferson Airplane and Californian bands to come and join us. But partly because of their kind of outlaw reputation but also because the cultural and political climate has changed, you know, swung against the counterculture with Nixon's election and so on, they don't get permits.
以及滚石乐队在60年代的故事，以那次美国巡演的最后一幕收尾。所以在整个巡演期间，他们因为高昂的票价而饱受批评，于是他们决定，由于他们是心地善良的人，他们将以另一场免费音乐会来收尾，就像海德公园那样，他们说让我们在旧金山——反文化之都——举办这场演出。我们要办一个小小的音乐节。我们会请感恩而死和杰斐逊飞船以及加州的乐队来加入我们。但部分由于他们那种不法分子的名声，也部分因为文化和政治气候已经改变，你知道，随着尼克松的当选等原因，反文化运动已经失势，他们没有拿到许可证。
So they decide they will do it at the Altamont Raceway, which is 60 miles from San Francisco in the absolute middle of nowhere. When we were on our tour, Tom, our US tour last year, we drove not a million miles away from the Altamont Raceway, didn't we? And it is, you know, California is a big place. You go inland, you're a long way from the cities. It's very rural. And that's where they're going to the kind of just a sort of suburban scrub of nowhere. And this place, it's like a bowl and the stage is at the bottom of the bowl, at the bottom of a slope. So a slightly weird arrangement. And to protect the stage, the management of the Grateful Dead, who have said they'll
因此他们决定在阿尔塔蒙特赛车场举办，这里距离旧金山60 miles，完全处于荒郊野岭之中。汤姆，去年我们巡演时，我们的美国巡演，我们开车离阿尔塔蒙特赛车场并不算十万八千里，对吧？而且你知道，加州是个很大的地方。你往内陆走，离城市就很远了。那里非常乡村化。这就是他们要去的地方，一种郊区荒凉的无人区。这个地方就像一个盆地，舞台就在盆地的底部，斜坡的底部。所以这是一个稍微有点奇怪的布局。为了保护舞台，同意协助组织的感恩而死乐队的管理层，
help to organize it, enlist the local Hells Angels and they pay them with $500 worth of beer. We mentioned the Hells Angels at Hyde Park. This is a very different atmosphere. They have billiard queues, don't they? And motorbike chains as weapons. So 300,000 people descend on this raceway. It's a very miserable kind of grey day. Everybody gets absolutely wasted
招募了当地的地狱天使飞车党，并用价值500美元的啤酒支付报酬。我们提过海德公园的地狱天使。这里的气氛完全不同。他们带着台球杆，对吧？还有摩托车链条作为武器。于是30万人涌入这个赛车场。这是一个非常悲惨的阴沉灰暗的日子。每个人都迅速
very quickly, very drunk. There's a lot of fighting and by the time the stones come on the mood has got very ugly. If you watch the footage Mick Jagger is constantly saying cool down guys, cool down and all this kind of thing. They have to stop the third song, Sympathy for the Devil. It's actually where the stones kind of slightly satanic pretensions are exposed. You know, they're not really as satanic as all that because they're clearly very uncomfortable and very discomforted by the fighting below them. And then the fourth song, this fight breaks out between the Hell's Angels and an 18-year-old black man called Meredith Hunter. And it culminates with this dreadful scene which you know if you're desperate to see it you can see it on YouTube. Hunter pulls out what
嗨翻天，喝得大醉。有很多打斗，当滚石乐队登台时，气氛已经变得非常恶劣。如果你看录像，米克·贾格尔一直在说：冷静点，伙计们，冷静点之类的话。他们不得不中断第三首歌《与魔鬼同行》（Sympathy for the Devil）。实际上，正是在这里，滚石乐队那种略带撒坦色彩的矫饰被戳穿了。你知道，他们其实并没有那么撒坦，因为他们对台下的打斗显然感到非常不安和难受。然后第四首歌，地狱天使与一个名叫梅雷迪思·亨特的18岁黑人男子之间爆发了冲突，
seems to be a long barreled revolver and one of the Hells Angels kind of parries him and then stabs him repeatedly and then the other Hells Angels kind of stamp on him while he lies dying. The Stones actually finished their set, they knew somebody was hurt but they didn't know how seriously. And then they effectively flee the scene by helicopter. And it turns out that Meredith Hunter wasn't the only person killed that day. So two fans were run over by a car and another drowned in a drainage ditch. And at the time, it was seen as the sort of the symbolic punctuation point at the end of the 1960s.
高潮是这个可怕的场景，如果你非常想看，可以在油管上看到。亨特拔出了一把看起来像是长管左轮手枪的东西，其中一个地狱天使挡开他，然后多次捅了他，接着其他地狱天使在他濒死时对他疯狂踩踏。滚石乐队实际上完成了他们的演出，他们知道有人受伤了，但不知道伤得有多严重。然后他们实际上乘直升机逃离了现场。事实证明，梅雷迪思·亨特并不是那天被杀的唯一一人。另外还有两名粉丝被汽车撞倒，另一人在排水沟里溺亡。在当时，这被视为20世纪60年代末期的一个象征性标点符号。
I mean, literally is at the end of the 1960s, is at the very end of 1969. But all the kind of rock critics and stuff said, oh my gosh, you could hardly find a better kind of encapsulation of the changing mood and so on. The US rock writer Ralph Gleeson, a few months later, wrote, if the name Woodstock has come to denote the flowering of one phase of the youth culture, Altamont has come to mean the end of it. Now I don't actually think that's quite right. I mean, I think it had already ended. Nixon had already been president for a year, the summer love was over. The optimism of the sixties was already a very distant memory.
我的意思是，字面意思上它正处于60年代的末期，正处在1969年的最末端。但所有的摇滚乐评论家等等都说，哦天哪，你很难找到比这更好的对不断变化的气氛等的概括了。美国摇滚乐作家拉尔夫·格里森几个月后写道：“如果说‘伍德斯托克’这个名字已经成为青年文化某一阶段繁荣的代名词，那么‘阿尔塔蒙特’则意味着它的终结。”现在我实际上觉得这并不完全对。我的意思是，我认为它早就已经结束了。尼克松已经当了一年总统，爱之夏已经结束了。60年代的乐观主义已经是一个非常遥远的记忆。
Isn't it because the Stones are the people playing at Altamont and they have provided the soundtrack over the previous two years for the process by which the Summer of Love kind of fades away that gives Altamont its kind of symbolic resonance? I think so, yeah. I think so. I think it's a different band, a less well-known band and one without the folk devil reputation, I think would not have been such a big story. I completely agree with that. Yeah. So, I mean, they're playing Sympathy for the Devil and that has kind of allusions to the Kennedys, doesn't it? And who is it shot them? You and me. And then you've got
难道不是因为滚石乐队是在阿尔塔蒙特演奏的人，并且他们在过去两年里为爱之夏逐渐消逝的过程提供了背景音乐，这赋予了阿尔塔蒙特某种象征性的共鸣吗？我想是的，是的。我想是的。我认为如果是一个不同的乐队，一个不那么出名、没有“民间恶魔”名声的乐队，可能就不会成为这么大的新闻了。我完全同意这一点。是的。所以，我的意思是，他们当时正在演奏《与魔鬼同行》，这首歌里有对肯尼迪家族的影射，对吧？是谁开枪打死他们的？你和我。然后你还有
Gimme Shelter, which is, I mean, I know that it's Keith Richards, isn't it? He was watching people run from a thunderstorm, actually, I think in Robert Fraser's flat, actually. But I mean, they say overtly it's about Vietnam. You know, that death and murder is just a shot away. And if they had not produced songs of that caliber, talking about violence, linking it into Vietnam, and then the fact that it happened symbolically at the end of the 60s,
《庇护所》（Gimme Shelter），我的意思是，我知道这是基思·理查兹写的，对吧？我记得他当时实际上是在罗伯特·弗雷泽的公寓里看着人们从雷暴中奔跑。但我的意思是，他们公开表示这是关于越南的。你知道，死亡和谋杀只是一枪之隔。如果他们没有创作出那种水准的、谈论暴力并将其与越南联系起来的歌曲，再加上它象征性地发生在60年代末期这一事实，
I can see why people give it this mythic resonance in California. Oh yeah. I mean, they greatly resented that. Of course they would. I mean, they would absolutely repudiate that. I think it is actually a tribute to the incredible power and resonance of the songs that they're putting out over 68 and 69 that it comes to have this resonance. But I understand why the Stones themselves wouldn't like it. Yeah. I think that's fair enough, Tom. Of course for the Stones,
我能理解为什么人们在加州赋予它这种神话般的共鸣。哦，是的。我的意思是，他们对此非常愤怒。当然会这样。我的意思是，他们绝对会否认这一点。我认为，正是他们在68和69年推出的那些歌曲所具有的惊人力量和共鸣，才使得它最终具有了这种共鸣，这是一个致敬。但我理解为什么滚石乐队自己会不喜欢它。是的，我觉得这很公平，汤姆。当然对滚石乐队来说，
you know, life goes on and they're in the middle of a fantastic run of albums. Two of their very best albums come in the next couple of years, Sticky Fingers and Exile on Main Street. Yeah, because they get back to France, don't they? Yeah, and they're producing amazing stuff in France. And I mean, by this point, what they've done is effectively invented what it is to be a rock band, I would say, to an extent that we now are so familiar with it, we take it for granted. Sex, drugs, rebellion, songs about, with the sort of slightly satanic pretensions, death, all
你知道，生活还要继续，他们正处于一连串绝妙专辑的创作黄金期。他们的两张最佳专辑在接下来的几年里问世了——《Sticky Fingers》和《Exile on Main Street》。是的，因为他们回到了法国，对吧？是的，他们在法国创作了惊人的作品。我的意思是，到了这个时候，他们所做的事情实际上是发明了什么是摇滚乐队，我要这么说，其程度以至于我们现在对它如此熟悉，以至于把它视为理所当然。性、毒品、叛逆，关于带有略带撒坦色彩的矫饰的歌曲、死亡，所有
those themes that people associate with rock music as opposed to pop music. It's the Rolling Stones who established the template, which is why I think they are the only band actually of that era that will be remembered as the Beatles will be. So of course there are lots of other fantastic outfits, but none of them quite for me have the same symbolic resonance as the Rolling Stones do. What do you think Tom? I completely agree. And I think that as with the Beatles,
那些人们将之与流行音乐相对立、与摇滚音乐联系在一起的主题。正是滚石乐队确立了这一模版，这就是为什么我认为他们是那个时代唯一能像披头士乐队那样被人们铭记的乐队。当然还有很多其他出色的乐队，但在我看来，没有哪一个能像滚石乐队那样具有相同的象征共鸣。你觉得呢，汤姆？我完全同意。我认为就像披头士一样，
it's the combination of incredible music with an ability to serve as a lightning rod for very broad cultural trends that gives them the status they have. Yeah, agreed. Although do you know the one person who doesn't agree with us on this? It's Mick Jacker. He was interviewed by Sounds in 1976 and he said a brilliant line, which makes me think
正是将出色的音乐与能够成为广大文化潮流避雷针的能力结合在一起，才赋予了他们如今的地位。是的，同意。不过你知道唯一一个在这方面不同意我们的人是谁吗？是米克·贾格尔。他在1976年接受《Sounds》杂志采访时说了一句精彩的话，这让我对他的看法
much better of him. He said, people overestimate the Rolling Stones. I don't think the Stones were as good as people think. Yeah, but bear in mind that's 1976 and punk is about to come. Yes, that's true. And by that point, he must be feeling, I mean, the kind of the tension between his growing years and the fact that he's supposedly the embodiment of the youth revolution, which to this day remains probably what people best now know the Stones for. But it's good to get back and be reminded of what
好多了。他说，人们高估了滚石乐队。我认为滚石乐队并没有人们想象的那么好。是的，但请记住那是1976年，朋克摇滚正要到来。是的，这倒也是。到那个时候，他一定会有这种感觉，我是说，他不断增长的年龄与他作为青年革命化身的所谓身份之间的那种张力——直到今天，这可能仍然是人们对滚石乐队最深刻的印象。但回顾过去并被提醒他们
they were. Yeah, I agree. Because now they're a parody of that kind of youthful anarchy and rebellion. But at one point, they were the embodiments of it. They were exactly. However complicated a way. All right. So that's the Rolling Stones. Shall we return next week with something completely different? Let's do that. All right. On that bombshell. Goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
曾经是什么样的人，感觉很好。是的，我同意。因为现在他们成了那种青春无政府主义和叛逆的讽刺模仿。但曾几何时，他们正是这种精神的化身。他们确实是。无论是以多么复杂的方式。好了。这就是滚石乐队。我们下周要不要带着完全不同的主题回归？就这样吧。好的。带着这个重磅炸弹。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。